you made it you made it you made it all
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos I am in
Canada and I'm
freezing it's very very cold here but
also the heat in my apartment is not
working uh so I'm recording this um
fully clothed and in bed with all the
blankets on me little update it's also
why I had to um move reschedule my uh
Chicago dates which was a bummer those
shows told out which meant so much to me
thank you to everybody that got tickets
we're looking to announce the date later
today so we'll have the uh new date uh
today but I do apologize that I had to
move that the schedule here on the movie
shifted around and there was nothing I
could do uh and I'm also very cold if
that makes makes you feel any sympathy
for me um I also have other dates coming
up not too many but I'll be in Tempe
Arizona for New Year's if you're in
Arizona come hang out with me on
December 30th and 31st and then January
5th and 6th I'll be in Brea uh
California at the Brea Improv this
episode boy I just started blabbing
about myself what episode is this this
is Glenn Howton Always Sunny Blackberry
which we talk a lot about if you haven't
seen the movie um Blackberry I gush
about it in this episode and that is all
completely legit I've seen it two or
three times now I'm Blown Away by him by
Jay Jay baraw the performances in the
movie are incredible the director is
incredible we talk a lot about him as
well but check that movie out um it's
awesome really really really love that
movie and obviously love sunny and love
everything that he does so this is one
of those did we just become Best Friends
episodes I love it I'm so glad you're
here just a couple things to plug up top
my Netflix special I am not for everyone
is uh is on right now my YouTube channel
is going to be shifting so if you want
to keep watching this podcast on YouTube
and seeing that I cut my hair for a
movie for example uh it's going to be
you made it weird on YouTube We're
slowly shifting that over I think this
one will still be on uh Pete Holmes uh
but in the New Year we're going to shift
over so you made it weird will be its
own channel so be sure to subscribe to
that we're going to start uploading some
old episodes to that so you can find it
and please subscribe to that and if you
like the show why not try you know this
by now why not try a pizza pick this
show is brought To Us by one of our
oldest Pizza picks which is alphab brain
from our friends at on it obviously I'm
doing this movie right now Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain Alpha Brain I have it in my
pockets I tell cast members about it
because I need to learn lines I need to
stay sharp I need to stay focused I need
to be able to concentrate also able need
to a be able to just as I can't talk
talk to people talk relate connect
access my vocabulary access my verbal
centers Alpha Brain is like fish food
for your ideas for your cognition for
your brain function it is it's not a
stimulant it's not like caffeine it
doesn't get you all jacked up just gives
you Earth grown ingredients that you
need to function at your Optimum it's
it's brain stuff it's a neotropic it's
like a brain it's like a brain it helps
with memory Focus concentration I wish I
knew about it in college I'm so glad I
know about it now absolute Game Changer
I haven't done a podcast a standup show
acted in anything or just gone out to
dinner without taking couple alpab brain
15 20 minutes prior and you absolutely
notice the difference go to on it.com
weird to 10% off and support the show
support your brain on at
onnit.com weird we're also brought To Us
by our friends at blueland did you know
we're eating and drinking roughly a
credit cards worth of plastic a week
that's correct the products we're using
every day are ultimately contaminating
our water supply generating hundreds of
microplastics that we end up ingesting
luckily our friends at blueland set out
to do something about it to eliminate
the need for single-use Plastics in the
products we use the most like hand soap
did you know that an estimated 5 billion
plastic hand soap and cleaning bottles
are thrown away each year if that's not
bad enough most cleaning formulas are
90% water which is heavy to ship leading
to excessive carbon emissions not to
mention the nasty ingredients in them
like chlorine and ammonia but blue land
is Reinventing cleaning Essentials for a
better you and a better Planet by
offering endlessly refillable cleaning
products with a beautiful cohesive
design that looks great on your counter
I can attest to that we have their hand
soaped in all of our bathrooms it looks
great and you put the tab in and you add
the water and it fizzes up and turns
into a Foaming Hand Soap looks great
works great and you're doing something
good for your body for the planet it's
awesome help just fill the bottles with
water as I mentioned droing the tablets
and the hand soap toilet bowl cleaner
laundry tablets all with clean
ingredients you can feel good about and
you Subs subscribe so you don't run out
I'm always running out and forgetting
before I had blue land so I recommend
their clean Essentials kit which has
everything you need to get started and
comes in beautiful light scents like
Iris Agave fresh lemon and Eucalyptus
mint blue blue land has an offer just
for weirdos get 15% off your first
purchase of any product and get cleaning
products that I love the look of and
love that they're good for you in the
planet for 15% off your first order go
to blueland.com
ymiw you won't want to miss this
blueland.com
ymiw that's blueland.com
ymiw all right everybody enjoy Glenn
Howard I'll be here very cold get into
it you know want to love us water you
got it dude if you got
that I thought thirst was a sign of
weakness oh
[__] your boy
dehydrated we only have Buri it alive by
liquid death sparkling and it has a
light it's like lroy great is that okay
yeah if you don't mind me burping
throughout the podcast you know I was
just in a like I was just in uh San
Francisco yeah yeah I said like you
don't like I mean what I'm with you I'm
actually with you liquid death was a
sponsor they're not a sponsor anymore so
like I can speak freely I and say I
don't like their their flavors you know
what else I don't like is that like I do
fasting and this is 20 calories a day
that's no good you the fck are you doing
like why are you ruining we know you can
do it mhm with no calories that's right
so why are you making this a 20 calorie
nightmare well maybe they don't want to
maybe they don't want uh to put like the
fake flavorings in it or the fake like
sweeteners in I hear you but spin driff
also not a sponsor totally like five
like 1 ounces of raspberry juice is
exact why did we bring science into it I
why I don't we should you know what I'm
saying let's recreate raspberries you
know what an easy way to recreate a
raspberry grow a raspberry that's right
yeah and squish it I I was so when when
spin came out I was so happy about it uh
because that's exactly what I would want
in a flavored uh carbonated beverage and
it's weird that I have very strong
feelings about this as well I just want
you to know you're in a safe space I
feel really well then why do you even
have this cuz they gave it to us for
free I feel embarrassed we're running
low and and we're going into the
non-sponsor if you want to support the
show don't buy liquid death buy some
Modern mammals and Magic miners from
first person don't buy liquid death now
does this stuff work I I yeah it does I
love it it makes your brain on fire like
shake it up and take it we'll have a
better chat well now wait a minute I you
want for shake it I've already had some
neut Tropics oh you did this might be
neut Tropics on on top of neutop I take
neut Tropics on top of nut tropics I
take Alpha Brain and I take magic mine
oh you do I think they're different
kinds I've tried uh I've tried the
allite you keep letting me interrupt you
it's really I love good no I know but
you're the guest but I'm noticing
heightened empathy heightened I'm just
complimenting it's like I I feel an
authority and I feel like your your
present and you're here and you're
powerful but I also see like uh what
what do you neut tropia like it's very
cool already I would much prefer to
listen to you talk than talk myself I
mean I I am definitely of that like I
hate talking I don't want to talk about
myself I want to hear more about you
you're only going to get in not trouble
but like you're only going to find
yourself in a story with no ending
yeah exactly like looking for the
bathroom in a restaurant also like I
know about me I don't know about you so
you want to know about me and I want to
know about you yeah I like that I this
is going to sound kind of whatever
however it sounds I want to know about
us this is a recording of us okay so
don't feel we don't have to Plum The
Depths but this will be us here we are
great in outer space Jesus Christ we're
floating in outer space now if I don't
if I don't hold hold like an ice cream
con I don't have to like do this the
whole time our last gu we doing this and
that was fine I didn't love it yeah okay
but you can do it but I can but I can
rest it here you can rest it if I like
okay yeah yeah just make it sure but
we're temporary beings in the Cosmos on
this rock but we're here together it's
[__] it's already I'm going to say it
it's already art it just is it is if we
decide it is you know what I mean like a
pineapple if you give enough meaning to
a pineapple it becomes art and this is
just a little slice of
2023 although I do want to say I spent 5
minutes yesterday trying to you remember
what year it was I I was I had that
issue the other day too yeah I was
convinced that it was 2024 I was too and
I was going cuz I remembered seeing a
meme that about the Ramones 2020 24
hours to go that's when it was 2020 on
New Year's Eve it was 20 20 24 hours to
go that's what the song's about no it's
just a funny coincidence like could yeah
they were prophets well I was going to
say well you know with that hair they
should be props yeah sure I mean with
2020 back then when they made that song
yeah it was like we were definitely
going to have flying cars and we would
definitely be on Mars already Blade
Runner already happened the year that
they said Blade Runner was is in the
past what wait what year does
Bladerunner take place can you give that
that a Jamie would you pull that up I I
don't remember a Joe Rogan reference uh
Katie would you please look that
up it's important to have somebody here
to back up whatever we say because ktie
is essential 2019 was the year Blade
Runner took took place oh my goodness
but we're not that far off you know uh
it goes both ways I well if you go to
Tokyo yep uh certainly feel as though
yeah yeah weirdly isn't that weird yeah
that is weird but if you went to Tokyo
there's a lot happening I was just in
San Francisco yesterday and there was a
car you know with the it's not just a
Tesla it's a man person car yeah and I
knew it was cuz it had a thing on it's
taking pictures 360 but are they they
they're not actually using them yet to
transport people are they or they are oh
they are that's yeah so this is it so I
I'm I'm in an Uber cuz I'm from the old
day yes and I'm driving past this car
and I'm like I know no one's in this car
I just know it and I looked and it was
driving down the street and there was no
one in the which you know what brings
back to the table what's that loud
farting you're in a car with no driver
that's your own little hot boox driving
down the road yeah wow you could leave
behind all kinds of farts in that thing
but they're definitely filming you I
give this a lot of thought so you got to
do a spread and release okay meaning you
got to you got to pull your butt cheeks
apart so it does make noise yeah yeah
that's a thing that's a it is that's a
thing it's a c that's a new thing that I
learned I didn't I didn't know that was
a thing until very recently like that's
a 2023 thing that I learned it might be
2024 could be24 it could be but yeah you
just figured it out well you're a
slender guy you got that MCC
bod you got Macon bod you got him a
conod I'll take that yeah that sounds
good I'm trying to compliment I'm less
hair I've got more hair than him though
got a You're a hairy guy yeah I got a
very hairy chest don't people like that
cuz it's kind of like you're pixelated
see you look very fit but like if I had
chest here I'd love it cuz it's like
you're always wearing a
shirt right yeah you're like a bear you
just you know always warm always warm
and always you know is he is he soft or
is he just kind of massive right right
like the old timey barrel chest did guys
but M I'm going to say it for the record
not just clickbait MCC has never had a
loud fart those are maybe one I think
maybe one cracks every once in a while
but he's never had like a brenon Frasier
in the whale that's going to be a loud a
louder more robust that's the
philarmonic there's just more mass this
isn't body shaving it's just a fact yeah
yeah instrument is the instrument his
butt the his butt being the instrument
that is going to produce more sound yeah
no for sure if you are folds yes
ripples if you're an in if you're a
musician you play the fart you're going
to buy the Bron frasure in the whale
nobody's me like you know what MC is in
the fart musician World he's an alto sax
yeah yeah yeah and and and Brandon
Fraser is the
tuba or the or the or the um and you
know what I want to get a parade going
or a kinera yeah you want a you need Tu
right right nobody's Turning Heads when
an elto sack starts that's why the Jets
it's a quartet you need three other guys
does it has there ever been like a tuba
solo though do people do tuba solos
that's not really a solo instrument
right so funny cuz there are bass solos
yeah which are so boring and I'm a bass
player I used to love it I used to love
a bass Solo in the Jazz group that'd be
like it's my time everyone hates is a
little bit of a let down isn't it if if
everyone has to hush up for your solo
it's not a solo you shouldn't the stairs
don't get to be the curtains you're the
stairs but I've never heard of tuba solo
now what I have heard are great some
great baritone Sachs solos are you
familiar with the band morphine of
course oh man that's the tube of
saxophones yeah and they can do like
a yeah morphine's great that shit's bad
I I love that band how could they be
called anything but morphine they sound
like like I imagine what morphine feels
like kind of like it's chill you're cool
yeah it sounds like you're smoking a
cigarette laying down mhm you know what
I mean right which actually feels seems
like it would be very uncomfortable I
mean as as someone who doesn't smoke
anymore no oh you did yeah I mean when I
was younger I know what you mean you
know I that memory came from a Christmas
at this house actually where I took
mushrooms and I really felt like I was
not in a supernatural or literal way but
I felt like I was living in another time
like I felt like it was
1973 oh really I felt like a groovy guy
in 1973 and I laid on it's actually
still in there there's we had this
little Tibetan daybed that came with the
house and they were like this is a
thousand years old so I'm laying on this
Tibetan daybed and I realized that we
had cigarettes in the house from who
knows why and I got one and I just laid
down and smoked it and felt like the
band morphine like I felt like the
coolest it's disgusting I'm you know I'm
44 now I'm like I have Clarity that's
that's really gross
well I mean yeah it's grows in every way
yeah I don't know it but it felt awesome
it's also kind of sexy of course it is
like I don't I I like the smell of
cigarettes I still do I but I can't I
don't know I can't get through a whole
cigarette anymore uh yeah I can't I can
only take a couple puffs and then I'm
just like n my body just won't do it
anymore I wish a pipe tasted how a pipe
smells you ever smoke a pipe it's been a
long time doesn't taste like how it
smells no secondhand pipe is the way to
smoke a pipe you want to be next to a
guy smoking a pip yeah I like that
cherry flavored tobacco kind of what am
I British it's incredible you I'm saying
that as a good thing it's like I'm
suddenly British yeah why don't we do
that anymore why don't why don't why
doesn't anyone I mean I'm sure there are
some people but why people yeah it's the
tamping ruins it the the badassness of
this is ruined by a dainty
like oh got to keep it going you would
think though I mean goes out on a boat
what what part of town is this like okay
this is Los felis all right so you would
think that in Los felis or Silver Lake
there would be people smoking pipes
everywhere oh yeah big Gandalf pipes
yeah the kind you just R it just seems
like it'd be a very kind of hipstery
kind of thing to bring back I think it
was really in I remember growing up in
Boston seeing what were hipsters then
which were just cool dudes with t in
the80s mhm every once in a while you'd
see a guy rocking a pipe really Mitch
Hedberg smoked a pipe did he the
comedian yeah he'd smoke a pipe stage no
that would be awesome he could have you
know what else makes a pipe not cool the
sound it
goes it's like very like Hollow sounding
a cigarette that that cushiony I'm going
to make someone who just quit smoking go
nuts but that feeling of the cotton and
you just go and they color it and it's
so throwback in 70s with the fake specks
you know when they probably first made
cigarettes there was something in the
paper that was spec and now they're just
like how our cell phones go to sound
like a camera oh oh you're saying that
they may have put something in it to
make it make a certain noise I think no
no not a noise although I wouldn't put
it past them I bet they're like they're
all about that mouth feel and and the
drag like parliament's very firm filter
do you ever smoke a parliament yeah yeah
yeah yeah they used to say it's cuz
George Clinton used to put a bump of
cocaine in it and you certainly could oh
that little Hollow Dev yeah is that was
for that was so you could do a bump of
cocaine in that Parliament the cocaine
administering cigarette and you can put
cocaine in a cigarette and then you're
then I think it's cracked I think it's
just become yeah you yeah yeah pretty
much I don't know I don't know I don't
know but I I it sounds wonderful you're
excited to find out well yeah again I
think I'm I think I'm just past that
like the I I'm just I think I'm past my
drug days I'm just I'm like the thought
of doing drugs now it just gives me
anxiety sure no I get it you know even
the even the neut tropics that I took
this morning yeah are giving me anxiety
right now you're a little like what's
this going to be yeah I get it is that
why and that's why you don't want to
drink your magic mine because you don't
want to be on camera if if I first of
all it won't disagree with you in fact
it'll calm you down oh really I don't
mean to do an ad for magic mind but it
has adaptogens in it which people are
like adaptogens are nonsense they're not
everything I take that has adap in it
just kind of cools me out which I think
at our ede do you so here's something I
struggle with did you do cocaine no no
no no I that was you asking me we all
know you do cocaine you famously do
cocaine
um I'm I like I feel and I maybe this is
like because I recently found out that I
have ADHD which explains a lot um don't
you kind of love it though it's it can
be a superpower it can be I like that
you're being honest maybe you don't love
it tell I can be it can uh when if I can
get into a good Zone with it if you can
focus on something can I ask you this
yeah hard to change gears very hard
that's me I hate being I hate like being
in the middle of something I I I can't
multitask I need to do one thing at a
time buddy okay yeah I love this
conversation I just told Katie before
you got here I was like Monday is
podcast day that's when we do the
podcast yeah and then I'll go and do
someone else's podcast and then I'll go
home that's Monday it's such a gift to
an add brain uh by the way they were
like you don't have ADD but you have
symptoms of ADD and I was like what's
the difference I I don't understand I
don't know what they I don't know what
they meant so you got a diagnosis yeah
and they said you have certain symptoms
of people who have ADHD but you do not
have it yeah I don't know what Now by
the way it's my understanding that add
is no longer a thing it's ADHD I don't
know why it ruins my joke CU you can't
spell dad without add cuz my dad
definitely had it and I sympathize with
him because when I think of something oh
[__] I did it today just this morning I
I forgot to reply to an important email
I just do it my dad had to write it in a
notepad and then maybe never do it of
course he was stressed out oh you know
what I mean yeah he probably had a brain
like mine yeah I think my dad I think I
maybe got it from my dad um he and I
struggle with the same thing we so I
can't read I it takes
me to read 20 pages of a book to sit
down and and be like I'm going to read
20 pages and and I'm not leaving leaving
this couch until I've read 20 Pages yeah
too long can take me now if I really get
into a Zone I could maybe do it in 40
minutes yeah okay but really it's going
to take me at least an hour and probably
an hour and a half because every single
sentence I read makes me think of
something else then I start researching
that thing and then that makes me think
of something else and then suddenly I
realize I haven't had enough to eat and
then I go get something to eat and then
I realize like have I hydrated and then
I realize like oh wait there was that
supplement I needed to take then I go
back to the book I read one more
sentence I start researching something
else that I forget I remember something
else that I had forgotten and the next
thing I know it's been an hour and a
half and I've read 10 pages yeah yeah
yeah I'm the same I have to listen to
books do you listen to books cuz it's
the treadmill it's treadmill you can't
stop that's a good idea it's treadmill
you can't stop you
go I do have to hit 10 back a lot yeah
because you start thinking about
something but it trains you it I think
you can kind of practice that Groove but
I I here's you want to get real nuts you
want to get nuts yeah let get nuts I'm
just kidding buy the book and the audio
book and have them race because when
you're reading it sounds insane but this
is for books that I really really want
to absorb have them race what do you
mean meaning I'm listening to it on
audio in the car okay and I'm reading it
because there's something calming and
nice about reading a book but I've
already read it I've already kind of had
it read to me oh it's like you never
read a book like if I read Blackberry
the book MH like based on the movie I
would love it cuz I'd picture you and
there's Jay you know what I mean it
takes his effort out yeah as opposed to
when I read a novel which I don't often
but if I read a novel and I don't know
I'm like okay it'll be Matt Damon for
now and then later it's like Tim
scratched his Gruff red beard and I'm
like oh he's got a red
beard the guy yeah I don't like redhead
Matt Damon you'll never see redhead Matt
Damon that ruins Damon dye that guy's
hair red is he a
star he's he's done he's Jesse plums
isn't he if you die his hair
red you you know have won the day with
that observation I mean I feel like that
that is what Jesse plens is Jesse plens
is redhead Damon he's redhead character
actor Matt Damon holy [__] same ski
slope NOS I say that with full respect
there's a little like I'd like to slide
down that face that sounds sexual I just
mean I'm a tiny
I'm a tiny
skier and I want to go down yeah you
want to and then have sex with them yeah
and then do a little jump and then and
then bang his face of course I mean the
only reason I'm skiing his face yeah
yeah yeah it's for the black
KN doesn't make any sense he's a he is a
phenomenal actor plans yeah what were we
doing before plans you know what I like
about plumes we didn't know we needed
them he's also one of those guys
that can do drama and comedy equally
well and I just I always love those
people that that can do both and and it
and it seems everything he does also
seems effortless agree yet extremely
effective it never feels like he's
underplaying it yet it never feels like
he's trying there are
actors look I actually like Jared Leto
I'm not [__] on Jared Leto but when
Jared Leto is being restrained I can
sort of sense that he's being like like
in Blade Runner speaking of blade runn
like we make Angels out of Flesh you
know like I can kind of feel him
choosing just 0 1% feel him choosing to
be cool with plin I never get the sense
that he's making any choice you know who
else plin is who uh he's Phil Hoffman
he's our new Hoffman I'm not yeah I wish
we still had Phil Hoffman obviously but
here comes the guy sexy sexy big you
know what I mean he's not plens isn't in
the gym he he fluctuates I feel like but
he does he goes all over but like I
prefer uh I don't know how to say it
soft plens is what I'll say like in um
oh what did I just see him in but I love
him in I'm thinking of ending things and
he's very oh wow normal that movie
was I actually found it quite relaxing
to camera was that that was the um
Charles Kaufman yeah right right right
right right yeah I struggled with that
one a little bit if I'm being honest
Glenn do you like restaurants I know you
do it's from Glen Gary Glen Ross uh
there's
a type of movie you watch it and you
immediately go on
YouTube Type in the name of the movie
and then the word analysis yeah expl it
really helps yeah and I'm shocked at how
good they are yeah these people doing
this people are amazing at breaking down
those things yeah incredible and I'm
like oh that's correct I've never
watched one you have to find one that
has a lot of views if it's some guy
being like okay this is what it is
but that movie is from the perspective
of this isn't a spoiler this helps us
enjoy it of Jesse pl's character as the
old man who's the janitor at the end of
the movie who never pursued the woman
it's very interesting but it's very
clear when someone points that out I I
need to watch it again I don't remember
it it's worth watching again and those
movies when you're sad are you like this
if I'm feeling a certain way I like
need a movie to like slide it on that
shelf and reflect back to me what I'm
feeling does that make sense yeah yeah
totally are you that way so it depends
yeah I I'm I don't know like I'm I'm
most of the time with movies I struggle
to get myself to watch something
challenging anymore and I don't like
that about myself like I I want to watch
I think it's just
because kids I was going to say I almost
said in that Gap play back the tape I'm
just kid I was about to say well you're
a dad yeah yeah I want I want things to
be easier now and oh Val and I can't
watching the office it's it's like a
problem what which one the the American
one or the British one I've seen the
British one so many times that we now
rewatch meaning that's that's that's me
trying to be cool it's the American one
which I think is excellent and she likes
that one and I like that one and we
watch that it's also more relaxing the
British one isn't relaxing in the same
right it's very anxiety yeah yeah yeah
but I see I actually do like that I I
love it too but what are you watching
what is this is your relaxing I go my
you know I
think uh I've I've become a little bit
of an adrenaline junkie when it comes to
movies so find myself yeah like watching
like he's in crank and crank too the
crazier the movie is the more the more
I'm interested that's an add thing too
yeah it's so stimulating it's
unstimulating yeah like do you calm down
in Time Square you know what I mean it's
that's too stimulating for me but what
does calm me down actually is really
hectic music yeah like I really loud
metal you know a tonal [__] like you
know my wife cannot understand my music
choices at all cuz I like things that
are complicated and strange get her on
the phone let me talk to her I'm just
kidding in the movie The Big Short
Christian Bale uh plays that genius who
figured out the housing crash and he's
listening to death metal and I'm like I
totally understand it like focuses him
it's so much that it becomes nothing
yeah push past too much but like a cab
driver snapping his gum will drive me
crazy cuz I'll fixate on it so okay so
do you have
misophonia I think I know what that
means and I do okay tell me what it
means
though um we should look up the actual
definition of it it can be anything it's
it's it's an unhealthy fixation on any
particular noise that causes you to go
into a state of fight or flight
basically that's me yeah chewing
snapping repetitive noises like pencil
tapping stuff like yes so dogs barking
Birds anything yeah no I definitely have
that I have I have dog I have dog
hearing once I and then once I once I
find once I hear it yeah I can't unhear
it and if it continues I can't do
anything else well I obsess just to join
you in that if you know what I hate
about leaf blowers everybody hates leaf
blowers what I hate about them you know
what I hate you know what I hate about
leaf blowers because everybody hates
them nobody's like oh good the leaf
blowers here you know mean oh good right
but some people like us I'm assuming are
are can be troubled by them and I'm all
about like get the pain to talk and like
so you can catch yourself believing
something absurd we can get into that in
a second but it's like I I think about
their finger on the trigger and it's
going and I think about the car I I
project onto that the irregularity of
the press to a carelessness that then
becomes a voice this man doesn't care
about me that is exactly exactly yeah my
problem with it he doesn't care he be
doing like a like a steady stream and
then stop he's just going there's a
disinterest that I find threatening it's
like sorry I just I rewatch BlackBerry
last night I loved it I watched it
months ago but I rewatched it
pleasurably but when they say you know
good enough is the enemy of humanity
it's like good enough there's like a
farting kind of LZ LZ fair you know it's
just like H whatever that I hate and if
it were intentional and focus I know
this sounds insane but I like outing the
into people that are not us yeah to me
it's it's it's exactly how I feel about
people chewing loudly what are you doing
filling the with your stupid ass [__]
noise and and I can't have my own thing
going on because you you need it to be
about you like it and it like it you
know like somebody on the subway you
know playing a switch at full volume a
Nintendo switch well yeah that yeah that
that's that's I was going to say uh I
feel like people like smacking and
popping their gum on the subway I would
just be like oh my God you [__] off
there's 50 of us on why does this need
to be about you and I'll Trace that all
the way back to I wonder if where you
live is being inconsiderate to you
whether it's your family or your
neighborhood like the Broken Window
Theory you live in a neighborhood where
the windows are broken you behave
accordingly so it's like how have you
been failed that's how I'll extend it to
a failure a systemic failure of humanity
that you have never been afforded
silence so then you therefore walk
around like because you were failed and
now I feel bad and I hate you it's a
very weird it's a weird thing here's the
one that I can't wait Val and I went on
our honeymoon to Bora Bora okay ever
been so did
we you did
not
yep shut the [__] up please cut this out
of the podcast we sound like such
douchebags did go to the Four Season the
season
well look we went to the same yeah we
went to the Four Season you can't cut
that out it's too weird of a
synchronicity it's so beautiful it's
incredible and it's a honeymoon and it's
great yep yep and you're going to
appreciate this
then it's the Qui I I you know the
greatest amenity of a nice hotel now I
sound like a douche let's just own it is
the is the con the agreement that
everyone's like it's like going to
Disneyland everyone's friend friendly at
Disneyland Four Seasons grown up kind of
Disneyland everyone is like we will be
civil and we will be quiet you love this
wait you love this no I'm laughing
because I want you to finish but the
something so outrageously against what
you're saying happened to us at the Four
Seasons but go ahead please please I I
cuz cuz you're absolutely right that is
that's what you're paying for yes at
dinner we don't know each other and I'm
we're on our honeymoons and I'm at the
table next to you am I going to get
drunk and come up to you and be like I
always no yeah because we're [__]
evening attired gentlemen we're just
pretending right but it's [__] but
it's a delightful [__] in the same
way that not everyone's kind but at
Disneyland you're kind hello Jim so you
like that everyone is behaving
themselves basically and there's a
decorum there's a decorum I suppose you
could say that really sounds snobby
preten but whatever um so day three I I
grew up with sound trauma meaning quiet
was safe any noise a car pulling in the
driveway the gravel driveway oh Glenn
the gravel driveway gives my brother and
I PTSD if we hear like a car pulling
because it's just meant Here Comes the
Boom basically it's like it's not going
to be chill in about 35 seconds so there
there was chaos in your household yeah
for sure in a controlled weird way so I
associate sound with I am not safe
that's why I want to get the to talk to
me this guy doesn't care about me the
guy but it also means I'm not safe if
he'll if he won't care about me in this
way how else will he not care about me
God my physical safety I would encourage
you to get curious about what the voice
is saying and you'd be shocked you said
fight flight what's fight flight fight
flight is I'm not safe I'm going to be
attacked I'm going to be well I I I went
to therapy for this I went to a HP I
went to a a hypnotherapist is that what
they're called hypnotherapist um because
my problem with people smacking their
gum was so bad and and um Rob and
Caitlyn on Sunny are both like they chew
gum or they don't do it as much anymore
but they used to chew gum non-stop all
the time
forever and if they were hear Glenn what
would you say to them no they know this
I've had this conversation with them
they know they know they know and they
couldn't understand they they and cuz I
finally had to say I was like guys I'm
I'm so sorry I don't I don't want to be
somebody who tells you you can't gum but
just so you know it drives me [__]
crazy yeah it drives me crazy and it's
not your fault to them it's not your
fault you don't you don't know you're
not doing it on purpose I realize it's
my thing but I just need you to know
that so that you can maybe maybe take
that into consideration yeah you know as
you're and I hope going nuts on your gum
I was that way on on crashing we had a
co-ed
bathroom that there was um two stalls in
it uhhuh and I just I I had the
showrunner say it because I couldn't say
it but I was like can everybody just
lock the [__] bathroom let's treat
that like a one seater I don't need to
go in there and hear ladies going potty
uh and I don't want them com you can
tell I'm a dad yeah and I don't want
them coming in while I'm going potty
uhhuh but you know what I mean it's a
sensitivity of like can we just but I
had Judah Miller I was like you say it
like it's you please cuz I can't lose
face same with
um you know it's all caring it's all
attention I really think like the
snapping of the gum is like don't you
know I'm here and if you don't know I'm
here you can take it
existentially do I exist like do we
agree that I'm also here that uncaring
can make you feel unsafe but I think it
goes back to that mammarian kind of
level of like okay then are you a person
that will push me if there's a fire like
do you only give a [__] about yourself
like I hate this right so anyway going
back to the Four Seasons day three or
something it's so quiet and I'm I love
just sitting in the quiet and
contributing to it being part of it and
you hear the ocean and you hear a bird
and the wind you're just like God damn
it this is so nice then some people
check into the little Hut next door they
go out on their little
dock it's a shared
Lagoon it's our Lagoon it's not your
Lagoon put a Bluetooth speaker out there
and just start playing [__] music
that Echoes throughout the whole thing
and my response to it
internally is as if Shredder and the
Foot Clan just walked in and they and
they're gonna take me down and there's
like 50 of them yeah I have like a
danger death and anger and here's the
voice I wanted to put to you is I and I
know you're going to relate I my
fantasy is you know I suppose you could
call the front desk my fantasy is always
to go out on the Lagoon put out a bigger
speaker and play my music and go do you
see mhm what if we all do it yeah what
if we all did this what if we all did
what you're doing yes because you're
King Ralph you is that that's exactly
what it is for me it's it's that feeling
of like what if we all did what you
doing you know that's unfair that's what
a society is what if none of us used our
blinker ever yeah what if everybody when
they when they wanted to get into the
left turn lane stuck the ass end of
their car out and blocked the blocked
the lane of people going straight what
if everybody did that did what if
everybody took up three parking spaces
when they only need one what if
everybody did that and so no that is
exactly what
I knew you would like it it is that lack
of I knew you would like it drives me
nuts but that's why you're a comedian
too of course and it's why the only way
to get it out you those observations
it's you have to turn it into comedy
because if you didn't you'd be an
insufferable human being buddy comedy
and I want to put this to you is like
taking five Xanax Val my wife will
diagnose you need to go do a show and
it's because I'm starting to get a
little like a a Paul Giamatti
character and she's like go do a show
and I do and I'm good for like it used
to be when I started I'd have to do a
show every night now I do a show I'm
good for two weeks that xanic stays in
my blood for not always but sometimes
two weeks I'm like clean and I'm less
concerned and that's best Pete it's the
same MDMA Pete is very similar if I if
somebody was playing music and I was on
MDMA I'd be like wow
sail away it's a beautiful song like I
would because I wouldn't see a
separation between me and them I'd be
happy that they were happy yeah but I I
sort comedy actually believe it or not
helps me get in a more openhearted place
and a calm Place yeah I I I've never
thought about it that way for me it's it
it's um I wonder if I wonder if it has
that effect on me and I'm just not aware
of it but
um yeah for me it's just a it's a it's
like it's like when you see in movies
the person like hitting the punching bag
yeah you know what I mean and they're
they're angry and they're just they had
a shitty day at work and they let it all
out on the well that's what's great
about Dennis on the show yes it is is
you can be a narcissist and buddy it's
so I'm playing all the people that I
hate as that character that's what I'm
doing I'm DAV I'm getting into that that
mindset of like I don't give a [__]
about anybody else it's all about me and
and just sterzing
it's the only way I can stay sane is to
sattie it and do you ever my heart
sometimes breaks that I'm like God I
hope other people have some way whether
it's a Japanese break room and you
destroy a piano with a crowbar I hope
you have
something without this jerking off to
internet porn is not good enough in fact
I would say that's hurting you I I don't
mean to be that guy I could be like
drugs and cigarette that's important I
just don't think it's as helpful as it
seems but like blowing off steam we need
something three-dimensional and creative
like your angst and your anxiety and
your depression your anger is is like
lava and and we can't funnel it through
a straw like internet porn or just
jerking off in general or any simp
eating it's too simple you need like a
playground for that lava to go does this
analogy fall apart you play you need exp
like a volcano like you need space and
collaboration I have to imagine on
Sunny isn't let me just put it to you
this way it's more leading I always ask
leading questions but it's like you're
with your cohort you're co-c conspiring
to ridicule what bothers you could you
imagine a better therapeutic exercise if
I was like you hate gum snapping hey
Glenn write a scene where where and it
is funny to come in I'm chewing G I have
gum in my mouth be like loudly chewing
what's up [__] you get to do that
it's role playing yeah yeah that's role
play that's great and then you get to
script what they say and then you script
what you say back no wonder we all feel
like we slept for 12 hours after like a
good scene you know what I mean well and
also I I think some people's Outlet is
watch is observing comedy right and
seeing someone like you on stage
that's talking about all the things that
them off that irritate them about other
people all the observations that they
have that they don't have an outlet you
are their outlet for that right that's
we are their their outlet for that and I
do think that that is a
tremendous contributing factor to the
success of of It's Always Sunny
definitely is I think people are
desperate for satire and they're
desperate to actually see awful people
act behaving in awful ways and getting
their come upins yeah like that's why
you know it's we're we're we're living
in a time right now where satire and
comedy in general is a a very dodgy
thing it's a very difficult thing to
navigate because people are so easily
offended or or we just we we love to
cancel people we love to assume the
worst of people right um you know it's a
difficult time I think maybe less so for
stand-ups I I think like you
guys it doesn't seem it seems like
there's still that's still a safe place
for people to do it but yeah and I think
the only reason we're still getting away
with is because we're grandfathered in
and and I but I do think that people can
sense that the people behind the show
are actually good people and they're not
the people that are on the show we're
we're we're we're having a go at all the
people that all of us despise I always I
love all this I could say on this for
the rest of the conversation it's like
when you have a dream it's not polite
it's not correct it's not clean but like
as humans we're built in to process the
complexity and the overwhelm of reality
with dreams and everyone does this yeah
and your dreams are so [__] weird and
inappropriate and it stands to reason
that things that are grotesque belong in
art that's why Sunny is going like no
let's be grotesque you know what I mean
by grotesque I don't mean gross you mean
exaggerated satire and and awfulness Rit
large all these fancy ways of saying
like let's do it loud because there
buddy it's not a theory that the human
animal needs satire it's a fact your
brain satires your mom and your dad and
that dog and your boss and your dentist
and that guy who gave you a bad haircut
in your mind and sometimes you're
beheading him with that thing you used
to cut clay
and that's what our [__] that's what
the [__] Pope does the pope goes to
bed and sometimes dreams and this is no
disrespect to the pope I'm saying it's
built into the human psyche that you
sometimes have a dream that you wouldn't
share and the artist the money I would
say for an artist is to deal with the
complicated feeling of like is this all
right because you're putting it on a
stage under lights instead of in the
safest private theater of our minds
awake or sleep but the I feel that the
money is for I come back to my hotel
room after a show and I'm like
wow I really you get a vulnerability
hangover or you get kind of like a but
what else are we doing like talk about
narcissism like I like telling stories
where I'm the idiot or I was selfish or
I was crude or rude or whatever because
using the stage or using your
as a way of being like a politician and
going like and the guy who's named Glenn
who's played by Glenn does the beautiful
thing like Highway to Heaven you know
what I mean oh I do what what is
accomplished what is cathar cathar sized
what is what has dropped off in watching
that dream yeah yeah I do think I yeah
and I think that
um I think it's it's also that the
grotesqueness that you're talking about
too is an important part of it because
it's it's taking you know something as
simple as uh a a slightly um
inconsiderate thing that someone might
do and saying okay not only okay what if
but what's the take that to its natural
conclusion like what is the most extreme
version of that right and you know just
because you are doing what you're doing
it's like a smaller version of what
we're starzing it's the same thing it's
maybe not quite as bad but we're trying
to show you the most extreme version of
what it is that you're doing when you're
being inconsiderate and awful yes and
and the response to inconsiderate and
and we and and us too like I mean you
know we're not we're not [__] perfect
like I i' I've been inconsiderate at
times I've I've you know what I mean
I've done dumb [__] you wouldn't be able
to write the show if you couldn't see
yourself all those impes are in me to of
course but that I actually think this is
something else I'm deeply passionate
about is like play it out like play out
get your pain to talk but you can also
get your anger to talk and if you get
your anger to talk to you honestly it's
murder it's like we're
murderous horrible the guy who's got his
butt sticking out and blocking the lane
you I'm not saying you want to actually
murder them but the feeling is very
similar and you play it out I I think
that there I think that and the way to
get rid of it is to look at it not to
deny it that's what I'm saying
definitely is to say oh no you wanted to
kill that person when we hear about road
rage we go can you believe it yeah I can
believe it because we're all [__]
nuts we're all [__] nuts well maybe
you can relate to this too like I I I
spend I I've spent a lot of my time
analyzing my own behavior and trying to
make improvements on it so that I'm not
being inconsiderate in the world and I
fail at it all the time but I I I burn a
lot of calories trying
to not be the guy who doesn't who sticks
his ass out like that I go I pull all
the way in the lane you know when I park
my car uh even if there's like a space
and a half like to the next to the place
where the parking parking spots end I'll
park all the way on the end so that when
that person leaves that whole I'm
thinking about all that stuff all the
time yeah and and that's a little bit
like you know crazy but it's also why I
get so angry when people don't think
about those things is I'm like why am I
spending all of my time thinking about
how to make the world better for all of
you guys when you don't give a [__]
right you don't give a [__] about us
like what you're saying is like the
narcissist only wins when we let them
win you know what I mean well they're
definitely winning in terms of like
they're they're having they're causing
me to react in a way that you know I
wish I didn't overreact you know to to
other people's behavior yeah but I don't
think it's crazy I think it's Alchemy
it's like you're taking this is what we
it's hard to say this is what we should
all be doing all I'll say is it's a
beautiful thing you're doing with your
pain because you're taking it and
getting curious about it and then going
what's something and you're not even
being this deliberate about it it can be
ugly and complicated and and even fueled
by Spite I'll take it I'll take kindness
however if you're going to park that way
so this all becomes parking spots I'll
take it however it comes I don't care if
it's for you hoping Beyond hope that the
guy comes to but
like here here's what's interesting to
me I'll go so far as to say everything
what we're doing in this world to a
large extent is yes and no win and loss
life and death right meaning even you
and I going like and we don't snap our
gum like my Uber driver is me sort of
murdering my Uber driver so that I can
stand Victorious and go I found problem
so even that is a meaning there's no
escaping it this thing that we're doing
even right now I'm talking and you're
not talking so I'm in a very micro way
sort of dominating you know what I mean
I I don't mean to introduce that energy
to this it's just kind of what's
Happening two people can't be talking
two people can't sit in the same spot
two people can't drive the same car you
know what I'm saying so like
acknowledging that we're Limited
by the way our brains work and the way
that we perceive reality and just going
okay what's the best we can do in this
game meaning if I do a kind thing and
it's really motivated by murder and
spite [__]
fine you know what I mean because it's
still right thing it's still a good
thing yeah Beethoven wrote blah blah
blah because he wanted [__] I don't
want him be too crude and say he wanted
to get laid but you know he did a
beautiful thing and at the end of the
day he probably wanted to be famous and
be revered and but he was also
channeling like the
Divine and he wanted when he went into a
restaurant people were like
lwig and that's okay it's all okay it's
all fine you just have to kind of like
loosen your grip on it and go like like
I felt weird saying I'm dominating but
like you that that's because I started
to judge myself like am I but then you
can just go like it's just the game
we're playing how what is the most
beautiful way we can play it and I would
say getting together with your friends
and making something even if it is you
do get to be a a known person and you
get to get paid and you get all this
stuff but you also get to do something
that people watch and
go do you know how [__] I could cry
someone watches and goes
like thank you like how I felt when you
knew what I meant about the music at the
Four Season yeah I yes yes you feel seen
you you were like okay I'm not crazy
like there are people who struggle with
these same things and you feel less
alone in that sense and how valuable is
that go now I want to tell you the story
of what happened let's start
recording uh so this this speaking of
the the social contract that you enter
into when you go to a lovely place like
the four season oh yeah yeah yeah what
happened so my wife and I we were also
on our honeymoon and uh we're we're
sitting in like a cabana you know by the
pool having some cocktails reading our
books whatever just having a lovely time
and you know there was this uh um older
gentlem you tell the story and it ends
up it was me what if at the end of the
story he kind of had like a soft baby
ass yeah and then I'm like wait that
was it was everything you said you
weren't go on um it was this it was this
older gentleman uh very tan you know
looked he he was he what I just have to
interject no place Katie go to a Four
Season go to like an like an elite place
or whatever you want to call it an
expensive place you see all you see are
Jaba the Hudson slave layers that's all
you see Jaba the Hudson slave layers you
see these tan disgusting men who made
millions and millions of dollars and
found a slave layia I know what I'm
saying that pretty horrible that is kind
of I'm just labeling it I'm just saying
it so I see it this guy found his Slave
Leia but I think but I think maybe he
found her like 20 years ago cuz she was
she was she wasn't like a she was
probably like I don't know in her 50s
yeah okay and he was like in his 70s or
maybe she was in her 40s I don't know I
I can't this was a while ago so I don't
I just remember he was a little bit
older you know not The Stereotype but
yeah she looked a little bit like a
trophy wife
is which is by the way why job the HUD
and slave Leia resonates when you see
that you go oh it's a big powerful
disgusting slob and a beautiful woman
who's chained to them and you go like
yeah oh Irene and Dan except the
difference there is that is that she's
chained herself to him as opposed
to but anyway she was sitting uh on the
edge of the pool like this with her feet
um in the in the pool and he was in the
pool so she's sitting on the edge with
her feet in the pool he's in the pool
he's got her foot in his
hand and he is using a pmus stone on the
bottom of her foot I have and
pising now for those who aren't familiar
this is a a rough Stone that you use to
Slough off the hardened and dead
skin and he was pising her foot into the
pool I'm dead and Jill and I were just
like I'm dead do we say we have to say
something I was like I I can't and I get
so upset that and I've gotten better
about this like I I I'm still not I
still struggle sometimes when I get that
upset to say
something she'll say something and I
love this about her and she was like I
have to say something and I was like yes
please do cuz I can't do it what do you
say could you please not exfoliate your
wife's foot dead skin cells into the
shared water that's basically what she
said she was like I'm sorry can you not
like you're can you not I don't know
what she said but it was something like
that can you not P her dead skin into
calm and they were just like and they
looked at us like oh these [__]
Karens you know what I mean like they
they were
like
really and then they said she I can't
remember it was either she I think it
was her she goes they have a
filter and we were like yeah but that's
disgusting and before it's filtered you
ever swallow a mouthful of pool water I
don't want to be able to prove we know
each other through my DNA you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah that is [__]
rancid it was it was the most outrageous
thing definitely the most outrageous
thing I've ever seen at a nice resort
like this and the fact that like did
they stop they did stop um they did they
did stop yes but they very begrudgingly
and as if like as if we were being
extremely difficult you were being
callous yes yes yes yeah it was I might
have Staffing on that one you know what
I mean you just go could you please like
I was shooting a a show and there was I
can't believe I'm saying this but
there's a woman and a man pming do you
know their skin into the pool would you
mind so much would you mind terribly
yeah they could do it so nice you're
executing them this evening in front of
all of us as part of the show yeah would
you mind
terribly cut the head off yeah that
would the
best everybody who was by that pool
would have been like
yes yes I have no problem with this can
I say that that is also a part of these
fantasies that we're
neglecting is it's almost like you are
like a political figure you get them to
stop they do often in the aftermath of
these situations people go thank you
meaning people need an advocate which
I'm not trying to force this Blackberry
which I'm obsessed with I think it's a
fantastic film and I think you're
fantastic in it thank you is addressing
something that you and I must love we're
watching it we're watching it and and
and you play um what's his first name
Jim Jim Bosley Jim
Bosley and when I was telling Val she
was in she wanted to watch it she loves
Sunny she loves you she loves Jay we're
in we want to watch it but I was like
look it is you we're kind of giving me a
throwing me a bone cuz I love movies
about American corporations I I love
them I think they're great allegories
for a human life like you how you have
to be careful how you manage your own
interior business so Jim as a character
but also as something that we all have
in our psyche is such a necessary energy
and this is what I said to her I was
like you know it's a bunch of nerds that
get like kicked into gear by like a
fierce guy
M
and what a fantasy it is and what a joy
I just want to give you this compliment
you're like you're you're now I look
Sunny may run like the F A Thousand
Years but like there will always be that
Glenn but now we are entering into Ed
Harris Glenn you know what I'm saying
we're dram dramatic Fierce kickass
Steely blue and let's be real bald you
were bald I'm talking like Trump and
let's be real you were bald he was
beautiful bald cut his hair off or was
it a cap we were still debating no I
shaved it I knew you shaved it yeah look
too perfect sorry Katie but Val also
thought it was a cap I was like that's
shav that's shave I have a lot of
questions about that but real quick Val
and I were having a conversation about
somebody and there's there's this like
soft openhearted where you're like my
friend is dating somebody and you know
they've been married four times and you
know they I'm making this up
and you know they do a lot of cocaine
but they also really love her and
there's something beautiful and
necessary like Sling Blade sometimes you
just hit it with a sling blade it's not
it's not beautiful it's not nuanced but
sometimes and I do this with Val I go
yeah he's been married four times and he
does
coke like you going in the movie he like
yeah they took you for a ride that's
[__] done give me the phone give me
the phone I
[__] love it and you do it to
Perfection not just the character but
the energy of like we all sometimes have
to go I was talking to an Uber driver in
Utah and she was going on and on about
all I said was are you from Utah and she
talked for 20 minutes guilt guilt ridden
about how she's never left and how she
wants to leave I never all I said was I
love it here do you love it here are you
from here 20 minute monologue about how
she feels bad that she's never and she's
like maybe I'll leave but you know
there's four this is what she said
there's four seasons here I'm like come
on and then she goes and I know where to
take my car when it's
broken I'm like you're Yelp and Four
Seasons away from any other place you're
clearly stuck and she's like but I you
know I want to leave and my gim balsley
wants to go you're never going to leave
I just want to tell you you're never
going to leave right you're never going
to leave leave he's been married four
times and he hases cocaine you're never
going to leave
and [__] love it cuz I need it I have
people like that in my life I had a
therapist like that they would just name
it and go they're [__] you they're
[__] you stop it would you just talk
about that energy I mean or whatever
that made you think of well yeah I mean
it's it's wish fulfillment on my part
certainly um yeah because that there are
times in my life where I wish I could be
more like Jim Jim bowsley in the in the
Four Season pool would be like are you
[__] kidding me yeah are you [__]
kidding me yeah yeah yeah do you mind if
I shave my armpits there's a filter I'll
shave my armpits what if I just take a
[__] will the filter get that yeah and
you're just going
like like someone's cooking cookies it's
amazing go on that is no I think uh I
think that's maybe part of what makes
that character work uh in terms of of
his roote ability I think you know for
as as Brash and authoritarian and you
know tyrannical as he can
be uh I think a lot of people are
watching that character and going yeah
finally somebody [__] saying
something like you know what I mean and
he's a little out of control and he
overdo it at times but I think it's the
reason you're rooting for him is because
you understand the rationale and I think
a lot of us do wish we could be more
assertive in the ways that he's
assertive um you know I I I admire him
for that there are other things that I
don't admire about that character um I
think there's a petulance that honestly
like I even have trouble watching my
performance like I'll buy I'll bu the
whole NHL that yeah yeah it's it's funny
because people love that scene and and
and it's become one of the most iconic
scenes in the in the movie you know me
screaming uh I you know you think I
won't do it yeah yeah yeah yeah you
think I won't do it uh but also me
yelling you know I'm from waterl where
the vampires hang out oh yeah
buddy here's your Oscar because try to
say I'm from waterl where the vampires
hang out and make it work and not have
people
go yikes well I have I and it's a little
out of focus shout out to the DP there's
like a moment of it goes out of focus
it's looking for you they're and it
works it helps oh yeah yeah I think
you're right I think somebody else
mentioned that to me yeah it makes it
like oh we just hot this moment yeah
yeah yeah yeah which was part of the
aesthetic of the thing I'm not sure that
they meant to do that there but maybe
that was just the best hardest job on
Set uh Focus poer yeah yeah yeah and and
that one in particular too because the
way the way they shot the way Matt shot
that movie um we a lot of times didn't
even know where the camera was he would
have it he would find a place where he
could shoot through 15 panes of glass
and he'd be he'd have the
camera 50 yards away what a genius move
on a on a long like on a long National
Geographic style lens and on this you
know little um I forget what they call
it like the it's like you know a little
ball like this little
um it makes it look like you're you're
doing a um a handheld but because you're
so far away it can't be handheld cuz
everything would just be like that um
when you're that far away so it's on
like a a gimbal a gimbal um gimly son of
Glo yes sure W holy [__]
[Music]
um that sounds like a real thing is that
a Lord of the Rings reference yeah it's
the D okay is he really the son of yeah
gloy is a great guy gloy you'd love
gloy I I can almost guarantee you I
wouldn't um you never see Glo I'm not
I'm not this riff is not even on the
maps and tolken Drew a lot of maps this
one's not even on the map well Glo must
have been in the didn't they wasn't that
Amazon wasn't that a prequel or was it a
I don't consider that a bunch of years
later I'm just
kidding I I don't I'm not into those I'm
not into the Lord of the Rings but um
yeah anyway uh he shot on a Gimbal and
and you know so yeah I think the focus
puller had had a had a difficult job
yeah for sure but but that must have
helped the performance they did that in
uh the movie once as well another
Glenn oh they they what do you mean they
sh super long lens well neither of them
were well Glenn had acted a little bit
but Marquetta hadn't really acted very
much so they would shoot them on a long
lens like half a block away know where
the camera was and and all the people
are real people real you can tell he
gets recognized a couple times but it
was how they naturalized their
performance so good is it great that
movie
blew us away like my wife and I went and
saw it we went to go see a different
movie and it had sold out so we're like
oh what's this once movie well we just
ended up in that movie and we were like
that's one of the best movies I've ever
seen I had just gotten divorced oh and I
watched that movie so can imagine the
table was set I was like I am a sinking
boat and it was incredible incredible so
good anyway um but that that that moment
I you know I had conversations with Matt
about that line because that line was in
the script and we both knew what it was
from it's a it's a reference to a do you
know this no all right so is it in Dune
you can no no it's it's a real interview
that this woman was doing oh he said it
no no no not Jim bostley not Jim bostley
this this woman I don't even know who
she is was doing a random like talking
to people on the streets thing and she
starts interviewing this random
guy and he when he he looks normal and
when he starts talking you're like he's
a normal guy and then and then he and
then after he gets about his second or
third sentence out you're like oh this
guy's not well he's not well and instead
of cutting it off she just let him keep
going and at one point he rips his shirt
off and says something like he doesn't
say I'm from water where the vampires
hangout but but he says like something
like that he says something
like he says something about being from
waterl and where the vampires are or
something like that and so Matt loved it
so much and he loved the randomness of
it that he just put it in the movie and
I was like Matt I don't know what this
line means I don't what the [__] am I
talking about like what does that mean
and he's like and he was like
it I think it means what we've been
talking about you know what I say when I
have road rage is I go you're King of
the Road I go you're King of the Road
yeah yeah yeah and my daughter you know
nobody else but you the cliche as your
kid repeats back what you say so
sometimes now somebody will speed past
cut over three lanes my daughter who's
only five will go you're King of the
Road and I'm like good I'm glad you have
that one that's a fun it's not where my
wife would look at me and go and go see
where you're teaching I think your King
of the Road is a great tool to give my
daughter to be like you can let out your
frustration but you don't have to be
like [__] you you [__] you know
definitely the80s alternative you're
King of the Road it's fine it's
acknowledging like it's actually bowing
you're King of the Road and I think in
American Business when you say I'm from
waterl which is where Blackberry was I'm
from waterl where the vampires hang out
you're saying we're you're doing what
we've been talking about what I've been
saying over and over which is like let
your anger speak get interview it what
do you mean I'll buy all of NHL means
you're trying to kill me I'll kill you
yeah and that's what the whole business
that's what the American corporation is
that's what the ego is it's like kill or
be killed I'm a vampire is the most
honest thing you think [__] Elon Musk
doesn't sometimes hang up the phone and
go like I'm a
vampire I'm a vampire I know he looks
like he's allergic to what he just had
for dinner but he's also a vampire you
know what I'm saying like it's honest
yeah it's it's primordial yeah it is
primordial that's why I think and that
is why people are responding to it and
that is why and that's why it's in there
and that's why I did
eventually I want to see take one that
might have been take one shut up that
might have been take one actually I
would love to actually ask Matt the
Oscar that's the Oscar um I should I I I
want to ask Matt that actually I'm
curious yeah because I remember I I the
whole time I was like man I I don't know
if I can deliver this line because I
don't know what it means
and then we got there on the day and I'd
been rehearsing the scene just like
going over the lines or whatever and I
was like well I've been I haven't had
I've had enough experience to where I've
said to Rob and Charlie I don't want to
do this I don't get it it's weird and
it's a little too far yeah in my opinion
and they're like just try one yeah and
then I do it and it becomes an iconic
moment from the show that has happened
15 [__] times can I interject the
that there's a Phil Rosenthal did the
Pod and there was a moment where Ray
hugs his dad and he didn't want to do it
and he did it one take and it's like the
moment from the series and he still
holds that over his head he's like you
got to hug your dad yeah he's like but I
wouldn't I wouldn't hug my dad it's like
hug your dad hug your dad yeah so you
have to hug your dad sometimes yeah that
and I knew that and I knew that once I
got to it and I was there on the day I
was like well I mean if it doesn't work
and I and I had also like I trusted Matt
at this point I was like he he knows
what he's doing he knows he knows what's
working what's not he's not going to put
it in the movie if it doesn't work so
why not do it like I'll just do it and
I'm going to do it and I I'm going to go
for it you know what I mean um and I and
I and and I was like if there is any
meaning behind this it's exactly what
you said it's just a a primordial yeah
scream no it's perfect it goes back to
what we were saying about dreams yeah we
dream about vampires we dream about
werewolves because we are vampires and
we are werewolves and what is more
vampiric than an American Amer
Corporation your behavior is very
vampiric and sometimes you want a
vampire that's the moment that's so
fascinating is is uh Jay Bell's
character knowing he should let this
shark in and he says you know who are
they're talking about how the other
corporations are like Pirates and he
goes you know who's afraid of sharks
Pirates right so we know that we it's a
necessary energy yeah it's like I'm
saying it's like they've had four
ex-husbands or wives or whatever you
sometimes you need that like the Sling
Blade yeah approach M so but I like the
moment Matt is the writer director but
he also plays yeah he plays Doug which
is like just I I didn't know that Katie
told me that before he started rolling I
was like I'm so impressed having written
and you don't direct but you know it's
very hard to be incredible in a thing
that you're also writing and directing
he has so much experience with it most
of his other things he's you know he
actually he doesn't consider himself an
actor at all
um cuz he's like I just play myself he's
like I play myself I'm not I'm not
acting it's in a way it's true like I'd
say he is an actor because he's a he
because there's always like a deep truth
behind what he does and I think that's
why his performance in the film works
because I always buy it it always feels
like he's telling the truth and being
honest it never seems like he's going
for a laugh even when it's super funny
um and I I admire that and um I have
such issue with him thinking he's not
act he's not an actor only because I
I've heard Lou say the same thing
Scandal noted but Lou CK is like people
say I'm not acting because I'm playing
myself but like okay someone's putting
makeup on your face and they're miking
you and they're asking you where you're
going to be standing and how you're
going to be turning and all that sort of
stuff and then you have to pretend that
you're anxious about a pitch
meeting what do you think acting is only
if I'm like hello Glenn well I can
relate to it I can relate to it in the
sense that I've I've written or or
Rewritten over 200 was that that right
no not quite uh over 150 episodes of
Television I still don't consider myself
a writer at all yeah that's because well
I don't know what it's because I think
it's it's I spent a lot of time typing
dialogue into final draft and but you
don't think you're a writer no that's
Mojo protection that's radio head going
like we don't want to leave I think
they're in Oxford or something it's like
it's not
Superstition but it's like I don't want
to
change how I think of myself because if
you start going I'm a writer you might
write like a writer and you want to
write like a guy who's breaking into
television and that's your mojo so you
can't concede it just a
theory I don't know that that's what it
is if I'm being honest
I
it's that every time I write I feel like
I'm writing out of necessity not because
I want to think and that's how Matt
feels that's how Matt feels about acting
he didn't want to be in the movie yeah
Jay barell said no you have to play Doug
like that's you you you yeah no you you
got to play good good you got to do it
yeah yeah yeah um the official Canadian
posture yeah yeah yeah
you
um yeah no Jay Jay was the one that
talked him into it uh he did not want to
play the role but he was like no but you
you he's like that's the only way I want
to do the movie is if you're playing
Doug um you know and so I think I think
recogniz and and so he kind of rewrote
the character to basically just be him
cuz the real Doug was not like that yeah
he was a little bit like that the the
character of Doug in the movie is uh a
an amalgamation of the real Doug and I
think this other guy that used to work
there um and I think he was almost more
the other guy than it was the real Doug
but um but so he basically rewrote the
character to be to cater to his own
thing cuz and again I can understand why
he doesn't consider himself an actor
even though I would argue that he
is uh because he's like I'm only doing
this because Jay wants me to do it and
because the way the character is written
now it's I'm the only person who can do
it and I know I can do
this and it's the same reason why I
write Sunny because I'm like cuz nobody
else can do it right like but us it's
it's our Core group of people and when
you remove any ingredients all of a
sudden it's not Grandma's meatballs
anymore it's something else you know and
I know that so I'm writing out of
necessity I it's not that I don't enjoy
it it's not it's not even that I don't
think I'm good at it I do think I'm
pretty good at it
um I just don't I just don't identify as
a writer because I don't have this
desire to write I'm writing because I
have I told FX that I was going to make
a show and I have to make it
now but I don't want to too if somebody
else could write it I would love that I
would love that everything you're saying
describes a writer to me well yeah yeah
but like whereas but I I do identify as
an actor because I want to act I don't
know about that
I I see
writer all three cameras get a mug um
yeah okay cuz you want to act and act
things but you don't want to write other
things not really I
mean
I have at times wanted to um I like the
idea you wrote the Sci-Fi thing we wrote
the yeah we we had that sci-fi pilot I
also wrote a script I wrote wrote a
feature recently with a friend of mine
um need needs some rewrites um but it's
good it's really good actually I think
it's one of the best things I've ever
written yeah very proud of it and it was
actually after we finished like the
first draft of that it was the first
time I actually thought like oh [__]
maybe I am a writer this is good yeah I
was very proud of it um it's interesting
well Seinfeld he he says there's he has
an image of what a comedian is and he's
always falling short of it again there's
another theory it's similar to my first
Theory though it's like you want the
engine to keep working and the engine of
aspiring to be the ideal of what you
consider a writer if that's Paul Thomas
Anderson or or somebody it's not that
it's not I promise it's not it's that
it's just that it's like I think in
order to identify as a writer I need to
have some internal engine that gives me
the desire to write and the need to
write like I have to it has to be
compulsive yes I think so that I mean
that's how I would Define it um like
I I I think you helped me understand
yeah yeah like if I never wrote this is
what I mean if if my if I had a
wonderful acting career ahead of me and
I hopefully I do uh and never into the
Ed Harris decade that's right I'm going
into my Ed Harris decade um and never
had to write anything ever again if
somebody was if somebody were to say to
me don't worry you never have to write
again I'd be like great yeah great
that's what I mean yeah yeah yeah I'm
writing something right now and I I I
really love it so I yeah I get what
you're saying but you wrote your show
too right yeah yeah and I I I'm sure you
get this all the time but I am
interested in the like always sunny is
always I said Charlie day did the
podcast as well um and I'm sure we
talked about this but the idea of like
and we can just talk about it briefly
but like The Gatekeepers right and then
it's like well let's just build our own
gate let's just talk about it briefly
because you and I are both products of
that no one in fact when crashing got
picked
up I said to
Val I'm like I'm trying to get in touch
with the excitement because you know how
it is everything takes a really long
time you write it six months later you
pitch it six months later they say yes
so sometimes you lose the feeling and
I'm like if I had auditioned for the
part of Pete in crashing and got it it
would have been so much closer like and
it goes into production next month and
we would have gone out and pop champagne
and eat an ice cream Sunday and danced
and all that stuff um we did do that
stuff but I had to get in touch with it
and the way that I got in touch with it
was like imagine if you got this part
like you would have freaked out but the
truth is and Jason seagull this way they
weren't writing movies for Jason seagull
maybe they were maybe I should take him
out but I'm just saying I think he would
agree no I think he was I think he was
creating opportunities for himself and
let's just let's just briefly just
because it's helpful I think a lot of
people are out there going and a lot of
actors are going like where's that thing
and Glenn on the show is the thing and
you wrote it and and then the Sci-Fi
thing and then this this feature like
the feature I just finished a feature as
well it's for me and if I auditioned for
it I wouldn't get it and I and you know
what I'm saying because you know they'd
call the
25 plenas of the world and it would go
to plens and I'd go I you're King of the
Road you know what I mean I'd have to
concede the point but you kind of trick
it by going like yeah it's it's what
Stallone did I know you and I both have
a lot in common with Sylvester Stallone
well you know the story that like people
want to compared to Sylvester Stallone
me too just kind of like the way you
talk the way I talk My overall sort of
like masculinity appeal my appeal just
yeah toughness MH but he do you know
this that like people wanted to buy
Rocky and make it but he said no because
he wanted to be in it MH just just just
because I think it's helpful for for
people out there and there are a lot of
people out there I think that are
probably listening that are like I have
stuff I want to do it I don't know how
to do it and and making it your own way
seems to have been your path and it
continues to be your
path yeah to a certain extent I mean the
the hustle is real for sure like uh uh
if I just sit back and wait for the
phone to ring it's not nothing's going
to happen yeah uh I have to be actively
out there if not actually writing
developing things and you know just
putting things in motion and maybe one
out of 10 of those things will ever
actually come to fruition but if I don't
do any of it
I don't know but I also can't just I'm
just not one to just sit and wait uh I
can't do it compulsion yeah yeah I I
want to make stuff but also like I don't
feel like I think I've also come to
terms with like I don't and maybe I'll
get to a point in my career where I've
got so many things coming at me that I
no longer have to spend all that time
but I think I'll still do it then
because they I'll still be unsatisfied
with 80% of what I'm getting yeah so
I'll want to to be developing the things
that I'm excited about um you know uh so
I think I'm always going to going to do
that but um I just think in this
business like yeah you have to be
developing things for yourself otherwise
it just nobody's going to hand it to you
yeah and and and I think I've gotten to
a point where I think for a while as an
actor I thought oh yeah you you do some
stuff you you you're seen as a great
actor and then eventually people will
start giving you things yeah um and I
think I was maybe for a while they're a
little upset that people weren't giving
me things and then I and then now I've
gotten to a point where I'm like why
should they yeah there's there's there's
there's other people out like I mean you
know right MCC yeah there's there's MCC
for Christ's sakes I mean he's got he
and I have the same body and he's
already a bigger star so they're going
to give it to him we'll take a break and
I actually know what I'm going to ask
when you get
back I was just this doesn't always
happen but just this week I was talking
to a couple friends about gut health and
boosting your immunity system your
immunity your immunity system is that
right boy it's early here but we were
talking about Arma colostrum they were
telling me about Arma colostrum and I'm
like no I tell you about armra colostrum
they're a piz pick and I'm on board you
guys know I'm always on the lookout for
ways to strengthen my immunity and my
gut health improve my fitness metabolism
and enhance my hair and skin Radiance
well I recently discovered an incredible
product which is Arma colostrum what is
it colostrum is the First Nutrition we
as humans receive in life it contains
all the essential nutrients our bodies
need in order to thrive and armra
colostrum has harnessed that it's a
proprietary concentrate that harnesses
over 400 living bioactive nutrients that
rebuild the barriers of your body and
fuel cellular health for a host of
research back health benefits what does
what are those benefits like I said it
reactivates hair growth and glowing skin
this is a benefit I noticed almost right
away I'm talking within weeks of taking
it I put in my smoothie don't even taste
it gets in me hair and skin Radiance
fortifies gut health and ignites
metabolism which is always you know as I
I feel like as I'm getting older my
metabolism starts slowing down like a
train I get it boosted and my gut health
always about that gut health fuels
Fitness performance and Recovery
recovery is the key one for me there
again I'm 44 after workout hurts more
than it used to it's wonderful to have a
secret weapon in my corner that can help
me bounce back after a workout or if
after honestly just travel stuff takes
it out of you so I love it we've worked
with them on a special offer for weirdos
receive 15% off your first order go to
tr
ara.com weird or enter weird at checkout
to get 15% off your first first order
that's TR r
ym
a.com weird talking about with my
friends I'm talking about it with you
Arma get into it we're also brought To
Us by our friends at ritual one of our
oldest and longest pizza piics and a
total game Cher for me and I can attest
people always say multivitamins or I
feel like I've heard my whole life
multivitamins you just pee them out a
ritual is different first of all it's
different for a lot of reasons it's got
a minty taste uh it's Trac able which
means you know where all of your
nutrients come from it's vegan it's
gluten-free it uh has a delayed release
that's the key so when when I used to
take regular crap vitamins I felt like I
I could see it coming out of my system
the first time I peed well ritual has
fixed that it stop it doesn't break down
until it's in your low intestine which
is where vitamins and nutrients can
actually be absorbed it's also a
Wonderful Life Hack because I fast I
fast all the time and I still take my
ritual in fact I'm not eating today and
I just took my ritual and it doesn't
upset your stomach so zinc try taking
zinc on an empty stomach it makes some
people throw up not with ritual because
it's not breaking down until it's in
your lower intestine which is incredible
it's also got D3 for your immune system
it's got Omega d uh omega-3 DHA uh to
normal muscle function heart health uh
is D3 is is muscle function what I'm
saying is I used to go to my doctor they
were like there are all these gaps in
your diet this is anecdotal this is just
my story started taking ritual no more
problems filled in those gaps it's
incredible get this essential for men is
a quality multivitamin from a company
you can trust rituals offering uh
weirdos 30% off your first month no lie
you guys know from the intro I'm
traveling ritual is one of those things
I have to bring with me so get it in
your routine and get 30% % off visit
ritual.com Weir toart ritual today or
add essential to men essential for men
to your subscription all right back to
Glenn all right here's what I was going
to ask you and it's completely random
but we'll see where it takes us there's
a scene in uh the wonderful Blackberry
where you smash a pay
phone here's my question look it seems
very obvious it ends with a shot of half
of the pay phone mhm so you eviscerate
this pay phone receiver I know I've been
in Show Business a long time it's got to
be a pre-broken phone like it had to be
rigged in a way that it would break with
the wires and good for that last
shot but you also slam it quite a
bit did you did you do the slam take and
then they they flew in the the half
phone or did you actually break it it
was
not uh it was not pre-broken it wasn't
even in the script actually the break
wasn't even in the script you just broke
a Canadian pay
phone well so I when when we got there I
asked Matt I was like is that is that a
real pay phone or is that our thing did
we build this and they like we build
that and I was like okay uh and so why
you're like don't worry about it don't
worry about it just roll just roll just
roll I think I told him I was like on
the last one I might just I might break
it yeah and he was like great you know
um but what happened was we did like two
or three
takes and whatever take that was uh I
didn't tell him that I was going to
break it on that one and I didn't know I
was going to break it on that
one it really really really legitimately
was one of those moments
where it just happened like I knew I I I
knew I wanted to do it on the last take
but I didn't know that was the last take
nobody knew it was the last take it
ended up being the last take cuz that
was the only phun we had yeah so I was
like well [__] I hope we got it because
it just it just was one of those things
where when I was doing the take I was
get I was getting legitimately worked up
in that moment and I was and I this does
happen where uh I can go to that
place uh and I was just I
was genuinely [__] pissed off in that
moment and I just started [__] doing
it and it wasn't breaking and I was like
I'm not going to stop until this [__]
thing breaks like and so I just kept
hammering it um and then it finally
broke and when it did a piece flew up
and hit me right above my eye I was like
[__] that could have gone in my eye I
cut my hand my hand was cut I had a cut
on my
forehead
um because yeah it wasn't it wasn't
scored it was it was like a it was like
a real thing but um but also like really
cathartic you breaking things is very
cathartic we're back to the Japanese
breaking room totally yeah totally so it
was it was a lot of fun I mean it was
great it's one of the great mysteries of
life that like screaming you know like
Prim I'm I'm surprised Primal scream
therapy isn't more popular yeah because
that stuff really yes like your body
wants to be mad we're just like no the
mind we'll just kick it around up in our
heads and yell in our heads it's not the
same you do amazing thing like um I have
a lot of respect for people who
can
um sort of like really get their inter
actors who can get their internal engine
going before the scene right they they
do what they is that nicotine gum it is
yeah I knew it you want some uh no no no
I'm good I'm good is it Lucy no it's
just good old fashion Nicorette okay all
right why I just I don't know I'm
noticing all these bioh hacky things
yeah notice the liquid death the the
neut tropics you've got the aura ring
and you've got the Apollo that's not an
AA ring but yeah the the Apollo is on
social mode keeping me kind of okay
uhhuh and then you've got the nicotine
gum for stimulant cognitive enhancements
yeah yeah yeah okay what do they say
it's like sorry I just no it's like it's
like I noticed you're pocketing it so I
was like oh he's not just chewing he's
pocketing I would just chew gum I don't
love gum yeah that much but you're not
worried about it it like having like no
like having like a little like on camera
or whatever oh I suppose I guess not I
noticed I shot a whole pilot with
nicotine come on lodged in my did you
it's a wonderful thing I had some on the
way over oh you did I did well look it's
I think it's interesting and worth
stepping out just a little bit we
started by the way don't let me I do
want to get back to the point that I was
trying to make before then finish it and
I won't forget nicotine gun okay don't
forget your thing uh or if I do who
cares
I've come to accept so I I I I think
something that that a lot of actors
struggle with I suspect um because it's
weird because in La people don't really
talk about acting they don't really talk
about their technique they don't talk
about that [__] in New York certainly
when I was going to college we did and
in theater everyone talks about their
process right in La no one wants to talk
about their proc that word it's like H
yeah and I suspect most people don't
want to talk about their process they
they don't have one or they don't feel
or they do have one but they don't feel
confident and talking about it because
they they're not sure it even works so
and I get that and I can relate to that
I feel the same way actually um I think
it's very it's a very awkward thing when
you're in theater the process you you
are part of a process you are rehearsing
with the other actors and the director
for weeks upon weeks before you ever
display the the the piece whatever it is
you know um so everybody's on the same
page you've rehearsed it all of you
together you figured it out together
when you're acting in a film you got to
go home and figure it out out by
yourself it's like how the [__] do you
do that it's really weird anyway um in
fact when you're auditioning often what
I feel is being auditioned isn't really
your performance it's your ability to
interpret the script correctly you know
what I mean it's like oh well it's this
kind of movie you know what I mean I
know director go ahead I found that I
had
to as a younger actor I would get in my
any time I booked something I would get
uh on camera I would get in my head
about it auditioning I I became I was
doing a I was auditioning all the time
so I became very comfortable with
auditioning so I started playing the
trick of like kind of what you said
about earlier when you getting back into
character for your character who is you
yeah for crashing like I would have to
trick Myself by I would show up on the
first day of set and and I'd be like
just think of it as an audition yeah
interesting because because otherwise I
would be overthinking it over analyzing
it instead because with audition you
don't have that much time so you kind of
have to go on Instinct a little bit yeah
yeah so this is what I'm getting get
where I'm going with this like sometimes
I feel like actors feel like they're not
supposed to do the thing that they've
read in all the acting books that you're
not supposed to do when you read
something you're not supposed to draw
conclusions about it right away you need
to read it a bunch of times neutral stay
neutral stay as neutral as possible read
it a million times and then slowly build
the character I think that's [__] I
think that's I think that's utter
nonsense or maybe that works for some
people
what I came to accept about myself and
I've never read a single book a single
act and I've read a lot of acting books
cuz I find that stuff interesting that
advocates for my position on this every
single one of them would tell me that
what I'm doing is wrong wow and I have
come to the conclusion that it is not
wrong it's right for me it's right and I
think it's probably right for a lot of
people I do the exact opposite the first
time I read it whatever I'm feeling
that's the thing that is the thing that
is myor star from that point forward and
I read it and I still read it a million
times but every time I read it it's like
prove me wrong prove prove that first
that initial feeling cuz when you go see
a movie you're watching it and you're
having feelings right away nobody tells
the audience like watch the movie but
don't feel a certain way about it watch
it again and then watch it again and
then see how you feel no [__] that yeah
if something's well written you should
have an initial Instinct of a if you're
an artist and I I I I I have why would I
ignore yeah the the first thing that a
script makes me feel yeah that's
everything to me I agree and I'm like
and so so and I build everything off of
off of that and often I'll realize like
maybe upon you know rehearsing it or
talking to the director that that a
couple things I was wrong about to begin
with that's fine I can make the
adjustment but why would I ignore that
first feeling that the script gave me
that's the that's the Bible for the
thing and it's very Jim Jim bsle you
know what I mean it's that energy not
the whole guy I just mean you know what
it makes me think of is when I'm doing
standup and sometimes I practice the
self-care I'll especially if it's been a
while I'll listen to a recording of me
doing the hour like the most recent
weekend before I'll listen to it and
that's prepping and going like oh yeah
that's how I sound that's how I do it
but I know that if I prep this is going
to maybe sound saying I'll be
forfeiting the like raw animal no I know
how to do this and no one knows how to
do this I'm gonna [__] do it however
I do it it might be the only time I do
that joke in that way but I'm I'm an
artist I live on the edge of the knife
and there's this like [__] confidence
that you get from not preparing that
sounds similar to going like sure I
could put on my reading glasses and have
a cup of tea or I could down the
espresso and do the [__] scene it's
the same thing I always tie it back to
sex but it's like you get into the great
love makings you've done you weren't
like I'm going to do that I hope we do
this position no you you're there you're
there and you're trusting your gut and I
think there's something David M says
interesting actors are interesting
people and it's trusting funny people
are funny people like Pete you're funny
do the joke and maybe you'll do it in a
way You' have never done it before and
you'll never do it again maybe it won't
even work that well but what's more
important is claiming putting the flag
in it and
going it's it's it's what I say before I
do stand up as I go whatever happens is
the show yeah you know what I mean
whatever happens to the show not did I
do it
right [__] you how I did it was how it
happened do you understand so this is
the so this is the thing right so
certainly when you're playing you you
you are you are yourself on stage like
you're very much the way you are now
when you're on
stage um it is a heightened version of
you but it's you yeah um it's your
writing it's your feelings it's your
passions it's it it's
you so I think you're right because so
the challenge becomes
though how do you get that comfortable
with a character who is not you yeah
right so that that when you're not
playing
yourself um but you want to feel you
want that person to feel as lived in and
and real as you are when you're playing
yourself um that that becomes the CH
that is the preparation to me right um
you know and then and then being able to
kind of like when so when it but when
the camera rolls to just be like okay
now I got to throw all that preparation
out and just see what happens yeah and
just live on the knife's edge like you
said and and just jump and listen and
play and there is no wrong you know what
I mean like there's there's there's
certain things that need to be hit but
you know you got to trust that you've
done the I've done the preparation I
know what beats need to be hit I you
know I understand all that stuff that
and you just trust that it'll be there
and if it isn't take one didn't work you
got take two like that's what I'm saying
that
there's an Eminem lyric that comes to
mind where he goes like um First Take No
mistakes something something that's weak
[__] or something I relate to that
rawness and I know Eminem is doing
multiple takes every rapper is doing
multiple takes but that that's the place
you want to be in meaning I was going to
say even on sunny or whatever there were
so many things that we did that were
like that might have even been
embarrassing on the day and seemed wrong
the example that came to mind is I'm I'm
the voice of the eade baby and I'm I was
shocked I know I was shocked at how
often they would use me talking to the
director in the commercial oh wow cuz
there was something about how I would be
like oh I see just like so natural and
they'd have the baby go oh I see like
but it was just me yeah and I wonder if
anything comes to mind like that that
was
wrong there was there was a I remember I
did a scene Gina gersan and she did
something that I remember on the day and
I was a new actor this is season one and
I was kind of like wow she just went
nuts like the character wasn't really
supposed to go nuts and she just did
this like almost like
childlike and I remember you know we
yell cut and I'm a comic and so part of
me is going like that was
weird that's what we used and she her
job was to risk embarrassment right and
then that became the thing
does anything come to mind that you did
that was like embarrassing or weird or
not as scripted or not intended and then
it just oh no that actually is what
we're supposed to be doing uh I mean
certainly on on Sunny that that stuff
happens all the time um but on on
BlackBerry uh yeah there were moments
there there are moments in the film that
where I didn't know know it was on
camera oh really that was just Glenn
preparing for a scene like by the way
like it wasn't even Jim it was it was me
yeah like I think there's this there
there's this one moment when I'm sitting
in the car like waiting for uh Jay's
character to come down cuz we're going
to New York to to pitch the phone or
whatever and I'm just like and I'm just
like you know what I mean and I'm just
like the steering wheel and I'm just
like you know that's me getting ready
that's me getting ready for the scene
but he's found it a compelling moment
you know for Jim getting ready for the
meeting in New York and it totally works
you know what I mean I think there's a
couple moments in there that are where
where I'm not saying anything that's
where it's just it's just Glenn like not
realizing that they're rolling that's
what Paul Thomas Anderson said they
wouldn't I don't know if he's a I don't
yell action guy but I think he would
just roll whenever Daniel de Lewis was
on set I don't know how much he was
hyperbolizing but he was like a lot of
the movie was Daniel would show up and
would just start filming him and I feel
like that has to be true yeah yeah I
mean that's Matt did a lot of that
there's a lot of Jay's performance in
there that's that there's a lot of stuff
that he caught like very you know again
he he shot it like a National
Geographic it's really animal
documentary an argument for digital you
know shooting it on digital because you
can't do that on yeah you just burn
through film I think Paul Thomas erson
is doing it on film but that's if you
have a100 million right that's Paul
Thomas Anderson very few people can get
away with that yeah yeah
uh very very cool um let me
see I just feel like there was something
that you brought up that I wanted to
touch on but it might be well we're
talking about nicotine gum ah yeah
that's kind of boring I remember uh Dr
huberman the internet psychologist or
whatever he is
neuroscientist was saying that nicotine
is like and I'm not even saying other
people should do it I'm just saying
there's certain things that grab you and
it really grabs me but he's like it's
like it puts you in an ideal state to
right or think because it's it it kind
of um
simulates
cardiovascular exercise yeah it does
yeah that's a good way yeah he's like
you're sitting uhhuh but it's like
you're going for a jog yeah it does feel
that way and that's why Hemingway all
these guys are are are smoking is
because they're getting nicotine in
their system yes so we found a a better
delivery system that's less less
unhealthy I yeah I mean based on I did a
lot of research no no you can say that I
mean anybody that takes you know a
podcast as a doctor is a dum dum but I
did a lot of looking into it and and it
it's very benign from the sources that
I've found same and then uh I remember
saying to Bill Burr who your character
does remind me of um I don't mean like
you were doing bill bur but I'm like
that kind of guy totally and uh although
he's pretty chill he's he's he's evolved
I think uh not that it's unevolved to be
that I love that but it's like you know
he last time I saw Bill he was he was
Chill Bill chill bur yeah but anyway um
Chill Bill is better what was I saying
oh I told build at you nicotine gum
because he loves cigars and I was like
why are we bringing carbon monoxide into
this like and I don't need a doctor you
know how there's that Trend oh cigars
aren't bad cuz you don't inhale them I'm
like you put them in your mouth LS what
the [__] it's not good to put smoke
absorbing whatever it is whatever
compound is in your mouth is absorbing
through your gums that's your mouth is
exactly that's how you're getting the
nicotine that's right it's all these but
you're getting all the other stuff too
it's all these uh Open Hands your mouth
is just thousands of open hands like
what do you got nutrition or so you're
putting smoke in so I said to Bill I was
like just I thought I was that's a funny
you can't give bill
he won't take it it's like your
character says when they offer him water
it's like Noah don't never take the
drink yeah thirst is a sign of weakness
you know Bill I could see Bill saying
something like that and I was like and I
think advice is a sign of weakness I'm
not sure about that but I was like Bill
you got to just try nicotine gum you
like the way nicotine Feels by the way
cigar has about 300 milligrams of
nicotine in it I bet which is like
chewing does it actually a hundred
pieces of nicotine yeah between 100 and
300 depending on the size it's insane
which is why you get high if you smoke
one so all that like lightheaded
well-being and also nausea and all that
stuff is because you just had way too
much nicotine right so I tell Bill I'm
like just chew the gum and in this
situation I'm like maybe I could tell my
dad something you know there's like will
the dad listen to the Sun what he say he
goes no I don't just want the thing I
want the I want the experience yeah yeah
yeah I want to light it and smoke it you
just and I'm like no you just want the
thing like I feel like that's a
generational I wanted to say to them
like if there was a gum that was
alcohol wouldn't you just chew a couple
pieces like you want everything you know
to sip whiskey well I think it depends
right I think it depends sometimes you
want to sit and have a cigar with your
with your friends and but if iig now I
look like an [__] I know I think you
look pretty cool I don't know that I'd
want to sit in here with you but no that
well that's true which is why a cigar is
the official uh appendage of Comedy
George Burns said this it's like because
it's invasive oh it doesn't care a cigar
is also it it's the fact that it's
phallic is perfect because it does [__]
everything around you smoking a cigar is
like no you'll breathe my air it goes
back to shaving calluses in the pool
yeah really I was I was going to say but
a comedian has sort of like shaving
calluses in the pool you know what I
mean there's there's an element of like
in my new hour I I talk about my butt
and I'm like and my butt kind of has a
double chin like it my butt stops and
then it stops again and the punchline is
go I don't know why I'm telling you this
I just it just feels like it's a rush to
share it with somebody and that's kind
of what it is and that's why when stand
up goes badly you're like you're right
why was I telling you any of that like
to get up on stage and be like my
daughter said a funny thing yesterday
and they're with you is the greatest
thing in the world but to me when you
don't have that connection with the
crowd and you're just talking about your
daughter you're like
you get the feeling you were at a party
and you talk too much yeah you're like
why did I say all that that's when
standup goes wrong yeah for me um have
you ever seen a ghost you seem like you
haven't have I ever seen a ghost yeah no
UFO nope anything unexplainable you ever
go to a psychic and they knew something
well I had a well that's go ahead this
was probably just a Just a Dream but
it's fine um I had an
experience a couple times in my
apartment in New York where it seemed
like I was being visited by something
there you go uh one time in particular I
was I remember I was laying in my bed
and I was asleep
um and I felt this um entity sort of
enter my room and my eyes were
closed it was like I was asleep but I
was aware of my position I was aware
that I was
asleep and then as it got closer I
wanted to open my eyes but I couldn't I
couldn't open my eyes and as it got
closer it was making this like humming
noise it was
[Music]
like as it got closer and I was and I
was like [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] I was
like trying to open my eyes and I
couldn't and it was just hovering over
me with this like loud
[Music]
like and it was [__] scary [__] and
finally like I did like get my eyes open
and it was still there what it was there
what was it I don't know it was just
this entity it was just this this like
blob not blob like a just a I don't know
like a shapeless kind of
entity black and the noise was still
there I opened my eyes the noise was
there and then it just
went and it was gone like so I opened my
eyes it was just there for a second and
then it and then it dissipated and then
noise went away and I was like holy [__]
yeah like that that's about as close as
any as I've come to anything like that
and then there was I had another
experience in the apartment yeah it
happened more than once goad I don't
remember the other time I just know I
just remember I just that was the most
intense one but I just remember that it
that that was that it had maybe happened
like two or three times very Salem witch
TRS by the way yeah that's very like a
Spector visited me yeah it was a spectre
that's what it was it was it was very
very real and the paralysis is very
normal yeah yeah okay so I don't I don't
know I mean I I don't know what that
means I it could have all just simply
been you know my brain and dreaming and
all that I mean that's probably what it
was but right that's the closest I've
ever come to what you're asking I think
that's pretty good yeah it was pretty
cool it pretty excellent yeah great
sound work it was you were like the
saxophone in morphan it was excellent uh
and then what was the other thing that
happened in your apartment uh no that
was it it was just multiple visitations
of that oh I'm but it felt like the same
entity each time it happened and I think
it happened like two or three times but
that's the one I remember that and there
was one ones where you weren't in bed I
think so I don't remember again this was
like I mean we're talking 25 years also
when the brain can't make sense of
something it tends to discard it it's
like we impose the limitations of our
finite Minds on reality even though
reality isn't imposed by those well so
do you believe in ghost is is that where
you at like why did I
vanish no it's just an I mean it's not
so much that I believe in ghosts as much
as I like the types of conversations
that it encourages I like the feeling of
thinking about it but I'm more what is
your mind anyway you know I had that I
was on LSD once and I was like but these
are just things I'm picturing like I'm
just imagining these things and it was
like what it it doesn't make sense now
but it was like
why is it a dismissal to say it was a
dream when we don't really understand
the phenomenon of that which is
observing the dream right could is it
possible that you are connecting to
Something in other words like that it's
not just your imagination but it's an
actual connection being made and even
what is your imagination is like an even
more perplexing question like if you
just picture a giant banana sitting on
that couch both both you and I can do
that and it's like what what are you
doing like what happened brain the mind
more than the brain the mind the
phenomenon that the brain seems to be in
control of or
channeling can make sounds like you can
hear like hear a flute you know what I
mean now make it like kind of one of
those Chinese kind of flutes or or or
make it a violin you can man manifest
sound more easily you can manifest sight
you can close your eyes and picture the
Reverend L Sharpton and there he is he's
not perfect but he's there so you see
that the mind is capable of Creation in
two of the five senses you can't do it
with smells really you can kind of
remember a smell you can't really
remember feeling as well but like you do
see the beginnings of manifestation as a
phenomenon of the Mind meaning
spirituality is like either we are
conscious beings that are experiencing a
material world or all there is is
consciousness meaning yeah right I feel
this and I think it's here but really
all that's happening is is your brain is
is making it so and the spiritual
approach would say that's because this
whole thing is one mind localizing
itself like a dream at night you
localize and this is all Rupert SP all
respect to rert I get these ideas from
him but he's like at night you dream of
a of London but you can't experience
London you have to localize yourself in
the dream to be a point of reference so
you can go around London even if it's
flying even if it doesn't have a body
you have to give it a camera basically
you have to become a thing so you could
kind of extend that to here and say what
if there was a mind that could localize
itself as millions of things and that's
that's a fun these are fun things to
think about who who's that author rert
spyra he's a non dualist I actually just
saw that's why I was in San Francisco I
went to a talk he was giving and he was
incredible and he is incredible do you
have any spiritual leanings that's
usually something we touch on on the
show um or another way to put it if you
don't want to
like a more General way to put it is
like what do you think is going on here
is it just kind of like a change in the
dryer or
yeah I don't have any [__] idea um I
don't but I also don't necessarily
aspire to know um not that not that I'm
not a curious person but I
also I guess I've come to accept that
we're we're not meant to know and so
there's a certain surrender that I feel
to that where it's like I would never
profess to
be uh an atheist because to me that's
just as well that can be certain is that
what you mean yeah the certainty of that
to me is just as ridiculous as the
certainty of of actually believing that
your religion your particular religion
is the right
and that you know whoever your savior is
is is is the only one you know the
certainty of that is is absolutely
[__] ridiculous to me the the
Ridiculousness of believing that God is
like infinite and all infinite and all
knowing and impossible to understand yet
we have a book that explains all of it
right you don't see that like people
don't see the D like how [__]
ridiculous that is that you so you've
contained God into this right this one
volume book and that and you buy that
and and yet God is every okay it just it
doesn't make sense to right right but
also to say that God doesn't exist that
also doesn't make sense to me that's
crazy to me like I don't know yeah I
don't know I'm that that's a beautiful
place to go it's interesting I don't
think Glen or Pete will know but I would
say that that in you which does the
knowing meaning your spacious field of
awareness the the part of you that would
if I say again this is rert Spyro but if
you say
are you
aware and you go yeah I'm aware so that
awareness that
perceives and experiences or knows knows
the experience of all the changing
phenomena in the world that can't know
but it is it that's what I would say
well it's yeah similar to what a Carle
refers to as the Watcher right right I
think he calls it The Watcher he does
yeah the witness is that what he calls
it the wit it doesn't matter a witness
is just a watcher
yeah but the fact the fact that you know
you can observe yourself feeling
something tells you that you're not the
thing and that impartial witness that
does the knowing I think the more you
explore it and it's here right now it's
you can you can recognize it and
remember it even while we're talking is
it whether not we can have the right
signpost pointing to it or not or expl
it I don't think that's correct meaning
Glenn and Pete don't get to go along for
the ride meaning I've had a lot of what
I would consider spiritual experiences
or or moments of self-remembering and
then when Pete comes back the best he
can do is a little volume of a book but
any of those good books would go this
isn't it you know this is the finger
pointing to the moon but the moon
isn't the Moon is kind of interesting we
always say the fingerprint of the Moon
because the Moon is so far away but the
Moon is looking out your eyes right now
but when you get even more curious about
it rert has this great thing where he
goes like there's awareness and we and
it appears to be in house in us right in
the same way that the space of this room
is open spacious free but it's the same
space that would be an outer space yeah
right but it appears so we're like rooms
where the space in the room and we've
been in the room so long we start
thinking where the walls and the floor
but you blow those away and it's it's
just one space he would say one knowing
there's only one and when you see how
impersonal that knowing is you you know
that it's not yours you're just sort of
renting it right or it's sort of
momentarily appearing as you all of this
is a fun thought experiment but the
reason I'm sharing it with you and the
reason I share it most episodes is
because it's not just a belief it's
actually something on your ride home you
can just try to listen to the listen to
Morphine as that knowing presence and
and when you are when you it's it's
again rert would say it's not an
efforting to remember that you're just
Consciousness it's actually the
relaxation of effort you withdraw the
effort to be Glenn and you rest in that
simple knowing the simple I am and then
listen to music just as that I am why or
do whatever you're doing just as that I
am why not so you can be in the Pete
club and believe what I believe who
[__] cares but because you can
experience this like um causeless peace
and joy that's why I can't share it have
you have you actually experienced like a
deep like sense of that like it's not
exotic you I bet you have too yeah he
would say that when you do something you
enjoy one of the reasons you enjoy it is
because when you like what you're doing
you don't resist the moment so you
surrender into it and in that moment the
true I am shines and this is why we're
obsessed with things like food and sex
mountain biking or whatever is because
it can kind of put us a little bit in
the backseat yeah you know you you when
you're
living when you're when you're living in
a moment of danger you can't um you
can't overthink you have to be totally
present survive it is it is why I like
acting it's it's it's why I like acting
and it's why I like snowboarding um
those two activities I feel like
I'm not fully in
control in a way that I like it gets
Glenn out of the way yeah it gets Glenn
out of the way and Glenn yeah he's not a
problem but he is a collection of
memories and what what rert always says
is close your eyes you don't have to do
it and just pretend it was your first
moment as if you were just a baby born
and tell me about yourself yeah like
what are you right and even if you say
something and this is what he did this
past weekend and you go like well I'm
spacious he goes well that's referring
to a memory that you know there's
spacious and there's confined but you
you don't have any memory so tell me
about yourself that's what he does to
people constantly just go what is it and
you just go most people are just left
with it just is I just am and that space
and this is his whole thing it's not
exotic it's not for the Chosen Few that
God has elected or whatever it's for
Glenn on his drive home to just go like
what if I just he Likens it to walking
into a room you've been in a bright
let's say you're snowboarding it's
bright in the snow is bright and it's
bright then you walk into a dark room
after doing that and you can't see and
what you have to do nothing you just
have to relax and when we do that in the
same exact way and just try to remember
not as a religion or a belief what are
you and just settle into it your anxiety
doesn't get to come your fear doesn't
get to come your identity doesn't get to
come so it can be unsettling but with
practice it becomes like oh I've been
this the whole time like when you were
eight if you remember a memory when you
were a
child uh Fred Davis says this was there
a sense of being there right like think
of a childhood memory were you aware so
that was with you then and it's with you
now and it hasn't changed it's neutral
like the space in this room your body
has changed your feelings have changed
but all that stuff is impermanent and
spirituality is trying to draw you to
the to the constant the the I am that
doesn't go anywhere and that's what get
out outside of time it makes me want to
I don't know my my brain goes
immediately to this place of like just
wanting to like throw my phone
away well because your phone because
it's such a
distraction it's like another
brain we just
don't I don't allow myself time to just
sit and be anymore ever uh the space has
to be filled with something at all times
whether it's work or conversation or
watching something or being on my phone
or typing an email or reading an
email and it's exhausting it's
exhausting and I'm sick of it yeah I'm
really sick of it like I was reading
somewhere recently that a common symptom
of ADHD is
exhaustion um you know there's there's
so many things for our brains to Ping
around about and think about and just
we're jumping around all over the place
and I think I'm burning more calories
than the average person because I'm just
[__] exhausted man like I just I went
I recently I was in Montana with a
couple buddies of mine and we barely
really even ever looked at our phones we
were just you know going on Hikes and
like playing disc golf and shooting guns
and fishing and um um and just hanging
out and it was and the air was so clean
yeah and we didn't have service a lot of
places that we went to and it was just
magical yeah and I was like
man I know and yet I feel I do feel like
I'm in control of it but it's it's like
we're all slaves like all right I mean
maybe maybe you're not and it's
wonderful if you're not I'm no relate
everything you're saying we slave L is
and Jaa is the phone yeah Jaba is is my
[__] email well Java is your
brain again I I I relate to everything
I'm not floating off my chair right now
I'm drawn to
this because for those of you not
watching on YouTube but I'm drawn to
this because I need it and and be I also
have I'll just say I have ADHD I mean
like that's that that seems very clear
to me and I relate to that exhaustion
and I also can enjoy my yearning you
know that like life like I want more I
want more it it just has been hacked
isn't it funny that Blackberry is kind
of the yeah the precursor to like
crackberry I remember exactly I mean
when when everybody was getting
blackberries then everything that
everyone loved about the Blackberry was
exactly why I did not ever want a
Blackberry which is like no but you can
you can check your email like wherever
you go and I'm like that's exactly what
I don't want yeah yeah yeah is to be
it's to have people be able to get in
touch with me everywhere I am and now
like they talk about the dopamine hit
that you get from like your phone
pinging I have the exact opposite
response every time my phone makes a
noise I want to throw it into the ocean
do me too thing because it's asking you
to change gears yes that's ad I'm doing
something and then the phone's like no
me though and I'm like but I'm you could
me you won a million dollars and I'm
still mad that you texted me like I hate
it do do you rock the Do Not Disturb
that's a huge you got my phone is almost
always on do not disturb and like and my
laptop is on do not disturb 100 % my
wife can sit there and be working on a
document like typing something like
working on something and just ding ding
ding ding ding and she doesn't even
notice it and I'm like oh my God your
wife sounds like a real piece of
[__] no she's like amazing she can focus
she can focus even through that she just
has a different wiring in that regard
yeah I can't I can't and that's good
that you found that because Val Val I
don't know if she'd do that but like to
find a counterpart find the balancing
energy to your
Neurosis she's definitely that is a good
technique she's definitely that I think
it's funny that you met your interesting
worth talking about that you met your
wife on Set uh right I did not okay well
let me tell you how you did it
okay I thought she was on an episode
called she was but we were we were
already dating at the time oh okay yeah
there goes that line yeah I just think
it's funny that PE I actually think it's
beautiful that people meet people while
they're working because it's like the
best for version like it's like you're
Juiced there's a lot of energy but I get
it both ways that is how Rob and Caitlyn
met um yeah but uh yeah no no my wife
and I met uh we had a mutual friend oh
okay met at a house party real quick
cute yeah it was pretty cute it's very
cute it was you've been married a long
time
too yeah for uh 14 years that's a long
time yeah we've been we've been together
for 16 years right 16 yeah wow that's
great I'm also terrible at that I love
more than anything but she'll be like
you know we've been married it's our 7y
year anniversary and I'm like really
it's like news to me how long have you
guys been it's been seven years it'll be
seven years since you've been married or
since you've been together uh I think
we've been together 10 years okay and
it's been seven years married but these
are guesses yeah and I'll be working I
I'll be in Bloomington Indiana on our
anniversary and there's no there's
nothing you could say that is like the
most loving thing to me is that it's
like I'll be telling jokes in a comedy
club on my anniversary and usually am
cuz if it falls on a weekend and I love
that I love that she understands that
and it's not an issue and right
Valentine's Day and and even birthdays
to a certain extent birthdays are a
little more special but it's like I I
received that as love that and I also
see it as ADD love it's like okay yeah
you booked a weekend on her anniversary
I probably asked her you know what I'm
saying I love that she lets me be lets
me be me and I don't have to be afraid
cuz I've had relationships where you're
afraid of the person right and that
would never fly I have a line in my act
right now I go so many of my friends are
afraid of their Partners uh they walk on
eggshells and I go cut and run get out
of that situation definitely yeah right
because I needed to hear that definitely
some people don't know they're they're
unconsciously reenacting the trauma of
their past and sometimes you need like
our boy Jim that energy yeah that just
goes you don't need this yeah you don't
need this that's why I'm so drawn to it
that's why it's so moving to me when I
watch that character and people like
that sometimes you just
need a cold shower you need someone that
goes like you don't need to be in a
garage making
modems and you don't need to be afraid
of the girl you're dating or the woman
you're
dating Cut and Run yeah and you know in
my experience most people that's not
enough and I think that's what's
frustrating to those like truth tellers
you go around and you go like you don't
need that you deserve this and they
don't do it and that can be so
disheartening to both parties but I'm a
guy that like if you go Pete snap out of
it you don't need to do that well I do
think the step one is feeling like you
deserve better right because I think a
lot of people don't think they do right
I think that that's that's it starts
with that right if you if you feel like
you deserve to be happy that you deserve
to find someone where look all
relationships are work but like I had a
buddy who
was in the worst most unhealthy
relationship ever and that was always
his thing he's like well you know I mean
relationships are work and I'd be
like right not in a coal mine yeah yeah
yeah they they they yeah but it
shouldn't be like all work all the time
constant stress that's a reenactment of
a of I totally somewhere in his life
maybe his childhood that's what it was
and you go this is what love is it's
supposed to be painful definitely and we
we form bonds there's these connection
between suffering and love and pain and
love and sacrifice and love and at a
certain point you know I'm so fortunate
I met value just go oh it can just be
kind it can be respectful it can be
gentle it can be silly and I say that
not to brag I say that to be like it can
yes and like I'll vouch for that I mean
my my wife and I you know we deal with
all the highs and lows of a of a
marriage and a relationship and and and
raising kids just like anyone does
but the majority of the time that we are
together we are happy to be in each
other's presence like I cons she is
definitely my best friend she makes me
laugh like nobody else makes me laugh
she uh she brings me comfort and joy and
I like to think that I bring her those
same things um and then there are times
where she drives me nuts and I drive her
nuts usually it's me driving her nuts
she doesn't usually drive me nuts
usually me driving her nuts in some way
and she puts up with it but um I wonder
if she even loves it too you know what I
mean she I mean she she she I don't mean
she loves Like She's suffering no no no
she accepts it's interesting yeah dating
an artist is interesting Val says that
too she goes pets 25 people a day and
she's like I'm never bored yeah yeah
it's true yeah she she she puts up she
puts up with a lot um when it comes to
that but you know and I can be I can be
volatile I'm never you know uh I'm never
uh
I'm rarely ever angry or upset about
anything that she does or did or even my
kids it's usually something else and I'm
venting about it yeah and she's able to
make space for that which I appreciate
you know what I mean uh because you feel
safe it's the same as a kid that throws
a tantrum I was just on an air and they
go that's good it means it means she
feels safe you did a good job that's
called what what is it called
the it doesn't matter I don't know but
but but you're right yeah that that that
is compliment to the parents when they
they when they go to have to go to
school all day and they have to be good
little boys and girls and they have to
hold it all in and then they come home
and they melt the [__] down and I think
a lot of parents are like why are you so
nice in the world and such an [__] to
me and they're like and you have to
explain this cuz that that's where
because they feel safe with you they
can't be an [__] out in the world
compl it's a compliment yeah no that's
it's really hard in the moment to deal
with that no we were just at the Santa
Barbara Zoo and Leela was on her back
having a full scream for a while and I
have to go like it's because she knows
I'm her homeboy I got her I got you it's
okay yeah and that's what we tell her I
know that seems kind of like whatever it
seems to be like yeah big feelings but
[__] man I would have loved that I think
it's healthy you know why I know it's
healthy [__] pass Pete we can't repair
in him it's what I do
now big feelings it's just that as an
adult you figured out how to channel it
into your comedy and you've you've
you've transposed it into something a
net positive for the world right right
all your frustrations all your anger all
your [__] irritations with the world
all your
misophonia and and and all that [__]
yeah you you have figured out how to
turn it into something positive for the
world to give people joy and laughter
and make other people who feel those
same things feel seen and heard you know
um again I you know I I would also be an
absolutely insufferable person had I not
found comedy had I not found an outlet
for it and a place to put it because I
would just be yeah I would just be angry
and irritable all the time well you were
saying that to me but that is exactly
what I would say to you and I think
you're just recognizing you know what
I'm saying like that's why you know
that's true and it's it's it's really
wonderful this this is this has been
great yeah really enjoy this I like I
like I really enjoy having these uh
deeper longer conversations appreciate
you making the time yeah it's it's it's
uh it's not a small ask and I was I was
very glad that you did it yeah I was
just sort of like I don't know I don't
know why with you in particular it's
maybe it's because your character is so
on on Sunny I was like that guy won't do
it you know what I mean I don't I'm so
very I mean I'm very different from from
a lot of the characters that I've played
there's there's a lot of me in
them you know I think the parts of me
that I actually ex need to exorcise size
yeah that I don't necessarily like and
don't want to act on in my real life
because again those are the thing that's
why I have trouble watching Jim balsley
sometimes because I find his petulant
really hard to watch because I see it in
myself of course whereas like other
people enjoy watching that you know
whereas I but I I have a tough time with
it sometimes no it's it's incredible and
but but when I first saw the movie yeah
I was like I I I had dinner with the
director and I was like
this you this is the most petulant
unlikable charact I'm like dude you got
we got to figure out a way to fix this
he's like what are you talking about
yeah he's like we've screened it for
audiences your your character's testing
through the roof through the roof yeah
and I was like why yeah he's
insufferable yeah no he's not and
they're and he's like wrong dude I told
Val it's about a guy who saves a bunch
of
dorks with like Dad energy and there's
that line right right up top where he
says you don't the director guy says to
Jay you don't have to do what he says
he's not your dad and I was like that's
a very
deliberate yes he is your dad and we all
crave when I see Joe Rogan being like
shut the [__] up and eat venison or
whatever it is I see this like cultural
craving for an involved dad even if it
has even if it's wrong sometime I'm not
talking about Joe anymore I'm just
talking about like
decisive strong jaw men or or or wom buy
buyself into trouble here we can always
cut this but that's why people buy
Trump's [__] yeah for sure because
he makes them feel like he's like he's
like I'm in charge I
know yeah yeah yeah yeah and and and you
know whereas like I see that and I go I
I find it repulsive and it all feels
very um you know it doesn't feel like
actual confidence it feels like I know
the exact opposite just narcissism a
complete lack of confidence to the like
anybody who has to talk about how great
they are all the time is clearly not
feeling good about themselves totally
like it reminds me of a dad that you
have bad seats at the ball game and he's
like we're going to float and you float
down to the good seats and not only do
you Ste steal other people's seats who
didn't show up you throw popcorn at
other people and you're yelling at the
players and you're lying to yourself if
there isn't part of you that goes like
that's a safe dad like a like a crazy
I I've said that about Trump before it's
like he's and and again I am not a fan
of trump and that is also but I identify
the appeal as the guy that goes we're
not going to school to get today we're
going to Disney World but then later you
find out he's going to Disney World
because the cops were chasing him you
know what I mean like there's you know
what I mean like there's the other
there's the Dark Side of it as well but
you can be like you know he's going to
throw sand and he's going to kick in the
balls and you get it because if you
never had that person in your life you
could mistake that for the for the for
the right version of it whereas the
there's the there's the right version of
that which is someone whose confidence
and
decisiveness uh is just inherent but
there's there's also kindness and
generosity and restraint restraint yeah
and and not this like Bluster but the
but just like a way of carrying yourself
to where that confidence is
automatically instilled in you because
you because you are actually those
things instead of just talking about
being those things right and I think if
you feel like you're in line to get a
loaf of bread like you're in a bread
literally a bread line and it's a really
long line and that's how you
feel you're you're more drawn to the guy
that's like [__] this it never happen I
don't know why I'm not doing the
impression like just like you you're
drawn to that and Joe Biden I think and
and a lot of Democrats seem like the guy
that's like it's fine it'll work out and
the implication is because we're not as
desperate it it seems I don't know how
the Democratic party came this way but
it's like don't worry we have money or
something don't worry we'll throw some
money at it they they'll accept you and
we're eating steak at dinner and I I
think again these are all just
compassion exercises but if I'm a farmer
and certain things are being relegated I
can't whatever it
is you go for the guy that's like I'll
fart in your tuba you know what I mean
like whatever it takes even if I do
think it is an illusion I think it's all
sort of an illusion I think it's all
sort of like pick your uh pick your
mascot well I I let's not go I I I know
I know and by the way I can't even back
up what I'm saying I'm just going off of
uh I'm not smart enough to have a deep
enough political conversation I feel no
neither am I actually I and I I I just
find Trump in particular fascinating
because he reminds me of our characters
on sunny oh yeah interesting um I blame
you I blame Sunny yeah it was those boys
Glenn Charlie they made me they made me
you watched then it became Me O I don't
even like no Glenn I'm here to confront
you you I am your father it's just like
Return of the Jedi remember that movie
oh my God I cut off your hand and I take
off my mascara I got a big fat
head you made me Glen look at me Glenn
I'm your dad It's Always Sunny in Trump
Tower I think I would react like Luke if
I found out the
[Music]
Trump yeah but we do have to culturally
back to full circle it we do have to
look we can't scapegoat and go this
guy's a blustering this blah blah blah
blah we have to go where is that in me
and let's let's sh the light on it and
the same with every conflict every side
of every is issue it's very tempting the
ego always wants to go you're King of
the Road and I'm the good driver when
cut to me sailing over three lanes cuz I
almost missed my exit 100% like it it
was us the whole time Glenn it turns out
it was us the whole
time would you say um keep it crispy
it's just how we end this was one of my
favorites thank you for doing it yeah uh
it's it's written in Legos behind you
but it's just it's just how we sign off
the guest gets to sign us off by saying
keep it crispy and just just I say just
that yeah well everybody keep it crispy
that was great wait you're you're on
Velma that's good voice over it was
clean it was clean very clean nobody
ever wants to talk about Velma you've
made me very proud
yeah I love you
boy you made it oh yeah you made it you
made
you made it oh yeah you made it you made
it you made it with oh yeah you made it
you made it with you made it with
all